Tone,
tone,
tone down,
and we're live.
Let's have a toast to hugh hefner.
Yes.
We lost one of the Great Dick slingers
of the 20th century.
Certainly did we lost him.
He literally had a place where guys
could go to be latches.
Yeah.
If you could just go and you had a
mansion where everybody knew there was
going to be a bunch of hoes and that's
why they went.
Yeah.
They went there on purpose and it was
guys that were notorious for hanging
around the mansion for going to all the
mansion parties.
Did you ever go?
I went twice.
I went once for a marijuana policy
project thing.
I think that was the company that was
putting it together.
A or a hosted something and there was
bands and stuff like that was kind of
interesting.
That's fun.
And then the other time I went was for
fear factor.
We did something for fear factor with
the playboy playmates.
Do you have to meet?
He'll.
I never met him in.
No,
never met him.
He's just,
I think by that time he's.
He's an old and I think he just wanted
to chill.
Yeah,
he was just kinda done.
I never went there.
I tried to get into girl,
tried to get me in and I guess they.
They googled me and she goes,
I guess I have enough credits.
Oh,
come on,
sit.
What it was I couldn't get in and she's
like,
they have to look you up.
And she was nice,
but they said no.
How long ago was this?
Probably two years ago.
Oh my God.
I know.
I didn't qualify to go.
Like I didn't qualify to go with his
fucking girls and fucking crazy.
You didn't have enough credits I guess
sell or maybe they didn't have the right
credits or maybe they just didn't care,
like whatever.
You know what I mean?
I didn't,
I wasn't even that mad,
but I was like,
ah,
whatever.
How credits.
Yeah.
Oh,
gross.
Yeah,
she said something like that,
but she was trying to be really nice,
like she was trying to let me down easy
because she felt bad because we were
friends since you wanted to go,
like you just don't qualify to come here
and look at these tits.
Just really hurtful.
It was a weird place because it was
super outdated,
like you heard about the grotto,
the grotto,
you go to the grotto and has a phone
from like the 19 seventies there and
you're like,
what is this?
They left it like for probably for the
vibe,
the old school vibe I guess,
or they just never updated.
It was weirdly,
you know,
he's sold the place or it was for sale,
but one of the caveats of purchase was
that he had to live in the building
until he died.
Yeah.
But it was like some preposterous amount
of money,
like $200,
million dollars or something crazy.
Well,
the land is really valuable.
So what do they do at that now?
Do they knock it down?
I mean,
is there no nostalgia to it?
Is it kind of died on the vine anyway?
Or do you fucking shit?
Well he has a son and his son probably
inherited it.
His son I think was running the
magazine.
They tried for awhile to have no nudity.
Oh,
terrible idea.
It's like fucking mechanic fucking thing
with no cars in it.
Who wants to just read that shit?
Stupid.
It's like having a New York Times
article with all ads.
Like what do you.
Where's the fucking intellectual
stimulation here?
You fucking idiots.
That's a really bad note.
Annuity is a terrible decision.
Yeah.
Well,
they were always in this weird area,
right?
Because Hugh hefner was like the only
acceptable pornographer like Larry Flynt
who did a lot for free speech,
who did a lot for exposing corrupt
politicians,
but they would show vaginas and assholes
and because of that he was always
thought as a gross guy.
Yeah.
Well even their social commentary was.
I remember when I was a kid,
that was one it ma.
Who is the feminist?
Gloria?
Gloria allred.
Oh my God.
I know and I think it was a gloria
steinem parody,
but it was like,
you know,
her licking the girl's pussy that had
period blood.
It was like some fucking viral thing.
He would do the most viable political
color.
He really showed his disdain of those
people.
He was great.
He's a crazy guy.
He's still alive.
That fucker.
He gets shot,
you know,
and paralyzed like way back in the day,
right?
Yeah.
Seventy seven maybe.
Was it that lady?
I think it was [inaudible] 76.
Yeah.
He's still got a bunch of casinos and
stuff.
He still out there kicking it,
but like who the hell is buying hustler?
I'm,
I a lot.
It's funny you mentioned that.
I had my manager got one today.
I haven't bought one in many years
because there's a.
I did an interview for them and it was
actually a really good interview and
they quoted me accurately,
so I'm in December's Hustler,
which is after today.
Wow.
So it's funny.
I bought a hostel for the first time
probably in 15 years today.
What magazines do that or December comes
out installed.
No,
that's so fucking stupid.
Why don't we pretend it's like new cars.
It's a 2018.
We'll have the fuck.
Is that even possible since 2017
monkeys.
I,
it's gotta be something about the
anticipation of getting it.
It's almost like when a halloween movie
doesn't come out October 30th because
you're sick of Halloween by then,
so it comes out like you say September
15th and then by the time Halloween
comes the movie's finished.
You're like,
oh,
fuck.
Halloween.
No,
but that makes sense because they're not
pretending it's halloween.
It's just a halloween movie.
Right?
Like they're pretending that's a
December issue,
but it's not decided.
It's not.
Yeah.
I don't know the thinking.
They come out like way in advance
usually a month of before,
but December.
This is kind of the new car thing.
It was always weird because it's way
ahead.
Six months.
Yeah,
like six,
six months before the year turns over.
They're already saying that it's a 2018
model,
but it's like it's 2017.
April when you're talking about is not
the 2018 model.
It's like weird.
It's like tricks,
you know,
it's like when you buy something and it
costs $9,
99 make it $10.
You Fuck?
What is this?
What does this penny stuff they want to
say under $10?
Yeah.
I,
I don't,
I don't understand.
It just looks better with the 99 then
the Ta.
I don't get it either,
but it does for dumb people.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
It's like you're.
You're appealing to people's mind.
Like the little part of their mind is
trying to save a little better and
better sound better.
I don't know.
I mean comedians have addressed the gas
thing for years.
There was a book about this.
It's called predictably irrational.
The hidden forces that shape our
decisions.
That came out about
10 years ago maybe.
Interesting.
So it's playing,
playing on the irrational thoughts that
we have about like specific anecdotes
about like say like a best buy ad and
why there's three.
My washing machines and they're really
trying to get you to buy the middle one,
but they have two other priced ones goes
into things just like that.
All over different aspects of life.
You all.
My favorite ones are when you're in
Vegas and you see voted Best Buffet,
best 10:00
PM show like Pi.
Who who voted for the best buffet?
They did vote on it.
Why?
Who are they?
Do they have to leave the house?
Like,
are you going to fucking buffet voters
in 20 minutes?
We're going to miss the buffet vote.
Who Cares?
But there is good buffets in bad
buffet's right.
Like,
where's a good buffet and big.
Do you ever go to the buffets?
I fucking love a good buffet if you
want.
The trophy is great rules.
Nice.
The Wynn hotel in Vegas has a tremendous
buffet.
Well,
the wind hotels,
tremendous.
Period.
I've walked through it but I've never
stayed there.
It's a phenomenal hotel.
It's like a very high end place.
So it makes sense that their buffet
would kick ass in here in la.
They have a good one,
uh,
at the um,
the four seasons on Sundays as I
might've said.
Delight to buffet.
Yeah.
Oh,
I've done the four seasons in Maui and
they have a breakfast buffet.
Oh,
what a great way to get fat.
It is,
right?
Oh,
it's tremendous.
They make you waffles.
They have the waffle thing right there.
Something about someone making you a
wall when they pour the waffle stuff
into that,
a little press and put it down.
You're like,
oh,
I'm gonna.
Have a waffle.
I'm just thinking right now about
melting the butter on it and before you
know what I did last time I put peanut
butter all over that motherfucker and
then I put butter and then I put syrup.
Yeah,
I felt great for about 15 minutes and
then afterwards I just want to.
But you feel fucking terrible.
Wow.
Much as you work out.
Like I'm surprised like you don't
because you burn through everything you
eat.
Yeah,
but you know what it is,
man.
It has nothing to do with that.
It's an insulin pump.
Your body just hits all that sugar into
your system and you bought us like what
the fuck is this?
And it's actually probably worse for me
because I don't do it very often.
Like if your body gets used to sugar,
if you're drinking sugary sodas all day
and you're eating white bread all day
and if your body gets used to processing
that stuff,
it has a better handle on what to do
with it.
Whereas with me,
it only gets it every few days.
So when it gets it,
it's like,
what the fuck is this?
Especially like if I overload,
like get crazy,
eat a banana split or something like
that.
Like Ah.
You feel it?
Oh yeah.
I worked hard.
I'm bad in la though with food.
Like I fucking go out for Sushi and
that,
that yogurt stop on Santa Monica.
It's my favorite place in the world was
then cheese.
No,
it's called the yogurts dot.
Oh,
okay.
It's on Santa Monica and I been there
for days where I've been in La for four
days.
I've been there four times.
I can't stop shoveling that shit and
it's my favorite fucking place.
Why is it so good?
I don't know,
man.
I've had yogurt that was just as good.
It just,
I,
I'd always felt right to go out for the
best Sushi and then go
down there and have some yogurt.
Stop.
Treat yourself a little jimmy.
You doing good with your life?
Well,
you know,
I was having a sad day Monday and
literally like a fucking fat girl.
I got my ex girlfriend who's my best
friend and we went and got yogurt.
I'm like,
I'm really sad.
And we went and got.
I treated myself to a little yogurt.
I just go up and down.
I'm just relationship nonsense.
I'm a fatalist,
but you're doing great.
I will do it.
Okay.
Do you know how many people would
fucking kill to be in your position?
Successful touring,
standup comedian?
Sure.
Assessable podcast or successful radio
personality.
Loved by all.
Chip has a great podcast or that's who
the successful podcast and the Norton
Empire is.
The fucking thing that you do with Matt
said,
Sarah,
you guys have like the best mma podcasts
in the world.
Thank you.
We have a lot of fun with that,
man.
Thank you.
It's great.
I Love Matt.
We talked about the last time.
I love him too,
but it's A.
Yeah,
it's one of those things where like,
I know that and I know that it's a fun
Gig and I love doing it,
but it's one of those things.
It's not about like feeling like I've
been.
I haven't been blessed like show
business given me opportunities.
I've failed,
but I'm not some unlucky guy who,
gee,
they didn't give me a shot.
They give me a million shots.
It's about being annoyed at yourself for
certain things,
so it's not about like,
I get a good apartment,
I make money.
I am very lucky,
but it's the rational,
like when you're feeling down,
you're like a rational thing.
No,
you can't.
You can't turn it around with your mind.
No,
I'm too emotional.
I react to emotionally,
but the next day,
like I had a great week since then get
out because she and I talked and I
realized I'm just being kind of fucking
crazy girlfriends.
Shit.
Yeah.
But I'm also not cheating,
but I don't know how to not cheat so I'm
not acting out.
It's fucking crazy man.
Oh,
so maybe part of your weirdnesses like
dealing with the fact that you're not
expressing your normal behavior
patterns?
Yeah,
it's giving up.
It's like it's given you have a huge
addiction.
Like I still,
I still look at porn and stuff,
but not acting out.
Not Having fucking girls.
The La is a deadly city for me.
Why do I come out here?
I got him fucking not deadly pussy.
Well,
sometimes when I'm out here,
I'm a very fresh boy.
Very Naughty.
I behave better now.
There's a whole ecosystem around that
here.
There really is a lot of gals that are a
little loose with the sex and they've
decided to profit off of that.
Yeah.
And they don't just have sex with some
men and not have to work a job and some
of them are literally just people I've
known for a lot like there,
like people you meet through the
business and they're just as dangerous
because.
And I mean for me because they'll do
anything.
And uh,
because they,
they liked the fact that I'm open.
So they're like,
oh my God,
guys think I'm crazy.
Like,
so it's hard just not to be unfaithful.
It's hard to not be fucking [inaudible]
fans are.
I've been talking about this for a week.
So I would up and down.
I've had sad that I'm great and I'm just
getting.
I don't have a girlfriend in six years
and I'm talking about it.
And then one fans like,
are we getting it?
You're going to girl friend.
You're 49,
you're being normal.
It's like,
Jesus,
you fucking rotten toad.
Can I talk about my life being healthy
for one week before fans get sick of it?
Well,
you're always going to get one person
who complains about everything.
Yeah.
I can't really bother.
You know,
it's just like,
yeah,
you're going to get that.
I mean,
and he's got a point two.
It's probably annoying to him,
which is why he said it,
but she or she.
Yeah.
Well,
shut her mouth.
Fuck you.
No Bitch.
I gave her.
I gave her a sarcastic apology.
I was like,
sorry,
I didn't mean to share something good.
Only keep it negative.
And she actually went back.
It's all good.
Like she believed the apology.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Well,
there's a fake feud going on between me
and Ari and Bert Kreischer and Thompson
and people for whatever reason think
it's real and so they're getting mad
that I'm airing out our dirty laundry in
public,
but I couldn't be more obvious about how
fake it is.
I even wrote,
good day sir,
at the end of my letter with all caps.
I mean it's just.
This is like a new thing.
Pray for Joe.
This is what it is.
Bert Kreischer,
our friend,
good friend.
Bert is a fucking raging alcoholic.
He certainly,
he drinks six doubles a night.
Yeah,
he's drinking 12 drinks a night and I
go,
are you serious?
He goes,
every night.
I go,
wow,
that is crazy.
I can't even imagine doing that.
That's incredible.
So we said,
do you think you'd get sober?
He said yes.
Okay.
So then someone said sober and run a
marathon.
I was like,
stop you guys.
He's going to die.
Yeah,
because first of all,
burt likes to pretend he runs,
but he really only runs on a treadmill
and I'm like,
that is not running.
You're lifting your legs up and the
things coming towards you,
it's not the same.
So now we started running on the
railroad and he's like barely getting in
a couple miles and he takes a lot of
breaks.
He's not running any fucking marathons
anytime soon and I'm certainly not
saying that he could do one after a
month.
Right.
So we said,
okay,
how about no drinking for the entire
month of October and you got to do 15
hot yoga classes in a month,
which is fucking hardcore hardcore.
I've done it.
I love hot yoga,
but it really does.
Where it really wipes you out,
it wipes you out.
Especially if you're not used to it and
you don't drink enough water,
you've got to really be behind the ball.
So everybody agreed to that and then a
couple of fucking days ago they started
saying,
we're going to be totally sober.
No weed,
no alcohol.
I go,
Whoa,
whoa.
First of all,
you fucks.
I'm only doing this to try to see if we
can get burt soap.
I don't need to not drink.
I could not drink for months.
It doesn't bother me.
Like me taking a month off of booze.
It doesn't bother me at all,
but me taking a month off a weed is
like,
how do you expect me to write?
I,
I use it to write.
I use it to think about things.
I use it to enjoy things.
I use it as a like a sacrament almost.
Do you ever think of trying a month
without you knowing you're going to go
back to it and that you're not doing a
direct of it,
but I know want to be bullied by a
welcher yeah,
no fear was supposed to see Burton.
Tom had a fucking contest and they were.
If they lost 25 pounds,
it was supposed to take them on a trip
to wherever they chose and Tom wanted to
go to Europe to watch a soccer game and
burt wanted to go to watch some crazy
football game and already completely
welch on the bed and then took off and
went to Asia for four months and left me
holding the bag.
Not only did he take off,
he took off and went off the grid and
don't think the two aren't related shift
fear.
I know what the fuck you're up to.
You didn't feel any responsibility to
pay that bet you son of a bitch.
Anyway.
I wound up getting them.
What do I get them tickets to wake some
basketball game.
That game.
Yeah,
there's a big game,
right?
Yeah.
So it was a big deal.
Flew him out first class the whole deal,
put them up in a nice hotel,
paid for everything,
so I paid for it and because they did
actually lose the weight and so they're
like,
we gotta come up with a new test and
somehow or another I got involved in Ra
got involved too and they're trying to
shame me into quitting pot.
It's like I stopped smoking pot all the
time when I go on vacation,
I don't smoke pot for a week at a time
when I go anywhere where I'm,
you know,
I,
if I'm in Europe for 10 days,
I'm not smoking weed.
It's not an addictive issue,
but it's something that I enjoy.
I could stop doing things that I enjoy,
but it sounds like an addict saying
this,
I don't have a problem with it,
but I really don't have a problem with
it.
I like it.
I like pod.
I'm not willing to not do it for an
alcoholic friend and a welcher and then
thompson girls dressing up like a
medicine man lately.
Like what the fuck is he doing?
He's wearing,
he's wearing some crazy steven seagal
outfit.
He's got wooden beads on and shit and
some crazy hat.
Or they loose fitting clothes.
What he's wearing.
Yeah.
No,
no.
He's in tremendous shape.
Oh,
good for Tom.
Tom Lost the weight and kept the weight
off because Tom is like really
disciplined,
you know,
which is why he just did another netflix
special and like three and a half,
four years.
He's done three Netflix.
Got.
Yeah,
he's a.
he's an animal.
There he is.
Look at his hat.
Just fucking hat.
Jesus Christ.
Wow.
Nice beer too.
Good frosting and the beard.
Nice and trim.
It looks good.
I love it.
But he's fucking healthy.
Look up the thinness faces,
but look at the picture above that.
Above that.
That one.
See if we get a fucking outfit.
Oh my God.
Pete's the feathers and shit.
Who Does he look like?
Who Does that outfit look like?
I've seen that photo shopped.
I'm sure.
What?
What does that outfit from that looked
like?
It was weird.
Who dresses like that?
Likes the golf.
It's looks like Steven Seagal to me.
The smoke in the back.
It could be like some Buddhist monk or
something like that,
but uh,
these motherfuckers are trying to shame
me and it's to quitting.
We'd some happening for us.
In fact,
I'm going to get high every day in
October.
You haven't thought of trying to just
for a month to see it,
to see how,
like if it gets weird for you,
it might be.
You might get some really good shit out
of it if you're cooling.
Yeah,
I mean I would,
but maybe another month.
Maybe I'll do it in November,
November,
but these,
this month they can suck my dick.
I'm going to get high every day.
You won't be shamed into it.
You'll do it when you want to do it.
I'll do it if I want to do and if I
really had an issue.
If I'm like,
man,
I can't get a day without.
If,
if I felt like I was reaching for it to
do things like I haven't smoked pot
today.
Today I went running to a podcast.
I like to smoke a little weed before
podcast,
but nothing today.
Nothing.
Zero.
No issues.
Yeah.
I think it would affect me differently.
Have you ever used you as a good example
of a guy like you?
You function well,
like you smoke pot and you do Jujitsu.
Like I didn't do that well.
A lot of people that do Jujitsu smoke
pot,
it's.
It's huge and the Jiu Jitsu community
you would think like a lot of people
have a misconception of Jujitsu where
they think of it as being a bunch of
like
really aggressive,
mean guys that are like attacking each
other,
but it's more much more bunch of really
smart analytical stoner sensitive nerd
type characters who are also like very
strong because they do Jujitsu all the
time or if they lift weights and get in
really good shape.
A lot of those guys,
it's because of Jujitsu and then of
course there's people that come to it
from like football or wrestling or
something like that.
They have a different attitude,
but a lot of times they fall into like a
Jujitsu mindset which is a very relaxed,
friendly mindset.
Jujitsu people are super friendly,
very affectionate to like all the guys
that met very huggy and friendly and
it's A.
I have noticed a lot of combat athletes
are like that,
but there's a gentleness to it.
Like we see Bernard Hopkins I've talked
to a lot and when you.
He sits right next to you and literally
he's a speed invade your space,
but it doesn't feel menacing or,
or weird.
It feels like almost like he's just an
affectionate,
gentle guy until it's an odd feeling how
you get energy from people and it just
doesn't feel uncomfortable.
Well,
you know where the garlic Bernard,
he's so confident in himself.
He doesn't exude any insecurities or
whiteness.
I mean,
he's an all time great period.
There's no,
there's not a single human being that
knows boxing that would argue that
Bernard Hopkins is at an all time.
Right.
I remember when he fought Tito Trinidad.
You ever see that fight?
He fought Felix Trinidad and I believe
he was 36 at the time and Trinidad was
in his prime and everybody really
thought the Trinity.
I was going to run them over and he beat
the fucking shit out of Trinidad and it
was a weird controversial fight because
he was in Puerto Rico and he took the
Puerto Rican flag and threw it on the
ground and everybody went crazy and he
wanted to kill him.
Yeah.
He wanted to get inside Trinidad's head
and get them,
get them to try to brawl with him.
And he did.
Bernard picked him apart.
Well,
he picked him apart and fucked him up
and then years later when people wrote
them off again,
he fought Kelly pavlick and this is
after Kelly pavlock and knocked out
Jermaine Stewart and he was thought to
be like the guy,
you know,
and everybody was like,
Kelly Pavlics gonna fuck up or an art
hopkins and Bernard Hopkins beat the
shit out of him too.
Who did finally knocked him his last
fight that will smith.
He was 51.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure.
I'm sure it was either 50 or 51.
He wanted to be 50.
I remember,
I think he had 40,
49 fights or whatever.
I know he wanted to fight when he was
50.
He wanted to Fight Mayweather for his
50th fight.
That was.
I remember him talking about that right
before he turned 50.
He was talking to her.
Would never fight him.
He's so much bigger.
Yeah.
I guess he was talking about cutting
weight or maybe it was just saying that,
but he talked about fighting floyd floyd
coming up at him going down.
If I was Florida,
I'd say fuck that.
The flight Pi did because he never
fought him about.
But I think that he was talking about
that when he was 49.
Yeah,
because floyd is a tiny man.
Yeah.
I mean floyd is a natural 147 pound
fighter.
Like when he weighed in for the fight
with conor,
you weighed 1:49
and Bernard was fighting one 75.
It's just so much larger.
Yeah.
Maybe he was talking about coming down
and I don't remember the conversation,
but obviously they would have had to
have a catch.
Right.
But he fought this guy,
Joe Smith Jr,
who's a young guy who's a murderous and
he just got fucked up and not through
the ropes and he fell on his head.
It was horrible.
Yeah.
But he had such a great,
huge bound to get,
you know,
he had to go down sooner or later.
But uh,
yeah,
just uh,
like a nice dude and uh,
I love guys like that who don't try to
give off just that shitty energy and I
don't think I've ever gotten that energy
off of fighters.
Well you won't get it off the successful
ones because to get successful you want
to have as few things that are in your
way that are cumbersome as possible.
Few Ego issues and a few distorted
perceptions of reality as possible in
order to weave your way through to the
top.
Yeah.
No,
I mean there's exceptions to that where
you have a phenomenal physical specimens
that are incredibly dedicated and
dealing with a lot of demons like Tyson
in his prime,
you know,
but I don't know if that would work in
them and may the same way it worked in
boxing.
Like I just don't know,
with all the variables and boxing,
like with Tyson or an mma rather with
Tyson in his prime,
he could just weighed towards God's Bob
and weave and throw bombs and,
and figure out a way to just smash them.
He was just so much faster than
everybody.
And he hit so hard and they were afraid
of him.
Yeah.
But I wonder if you're ever get to see
that kind of person dominate the way
Tyson did as a MMA fighter.
Like I just don't know.
It's weird.
I never care what their face looks like
when they walk into the ring.
Like,
you know,
when you don't watch videos,
like,
Oh God,
he looks frightening,
but you've pointed it out and he chews
gum.
Annie's high steep and the Oj when he
walks in,
he couldn't look happier.
Oh,
was so calm.
Josie.
Aldo won't look the guy in the eye.
He's terrified.
He's just kind of looking down and being
humble,
you know,
none of that stuff seems to work with
those guys because every one of them
knows there's so many ways to lose.
I don't know what it is,
but they don't seem to try that shit
with each other like boxers some guys
do.
It was a big thing with vandelay Silva,
vandelay stair guys down big time,
you know,
and Mirko Cro.
Cop in him had the greatest stare down
the history of pride.
They're just both staring at each other.
It was super intense.
I remember just like America when you
talking about his stare,
that's probably what every year he came
over to.
UFC was a 2008 when you were on our show
on k rock and you talking about this Guy
Mirko Cro.
Cop was coming over at his fucking and
we were watching his stare down.
Look at this.
This is Mirko versus vandal.
Vandal used to intimidate everybody,
but Mirko was the head of an anti
terrorist squadron and Croatia,
he didn't give a fuck.
And he was a world class kickbox.
So like,
look how fucking intense lately on.
He's completely unintimidated by that
stare and he beat the holy shit out of
Angela.
He was the first guy to really flatline.
Vandelay head kicked him into a coma.
Wow.
Yeah.
Just blam it was,
uh,
the second time they fought,
the first time they fought was his first
mma fight and they had all these weird
wacky rules like there can only be on
the ground for 30 seconds and they had
to stand in the back backup,
right?
Yeah.
They,
they hate Mirko wasn't really doing mma.
I mean you've sort of training in mma,
but vandelay was a champion.
I mean Jay was a world class fighter and
so they had some sort of a weird
arrangement and the arrangement was like
limited amount of time on the ground and
bunch of other wacky rules in that first
fight.
It was a draw because if no one finished
anyone,
that was the other thing.
Nobody finished.
Anyway.
They decided that it was going to be a
draw and the rounds were with a 10
minute rounds.
Well back then they were 10 minute first
rounds and then you'd have a five minute
second round in a five minute third
round if it was a championship fight.
But I think with vander and him they,
they shortened the rounds as well.
I don't remember the whole deal.
But then the second time they fought,
it was a legit pride mma fight and Mirko
had already fought a bunch of pride
fights and really got into the groove
and it become like one of the best
heavyweights alive and he just beat the
shit out of band that way.
I've never seen that stare down.
That was really intense that,
that was an intimidating stare.
That's Marco and his prime because it's
moving,
not moving.
Yeah.
But that you're right,
if you're dealing with the team,
you're the head of an anti terrorist.
Uh,
yeah.
We've got police group.
I guess there are police could have
sounded more like a fucking,
like my niece,
the head of it police.
But if you're like an antiterrorism cop,
I mean that's the face you have.
I mean,
you have to get information out of
people,
but he's most likely seen a lot of
people die,
you think?
Yeah.
Croatia is a hard place,
man.
I mean he's,
he's a hard man in a hard place.
And on top of being like a soldier,
he was,
you know,
the best kickboxers alive before he
wanted to mma.
So yeah.
Oh man,
he was amazing.
He was amazing.
He was very good as a kickboxer,
but really came into his own as a MMA
fighter because his style of kickboxing
was unique,
uniquely effective in mma because he was
very explosive and fast.
Whereas a,
some guys would be like more,
there'd be more methodical or technical,
like Ernesto hoost or Peter or some of
these other guys that would,
they would stand in front of guys more
and just pick their shots better.
Mirko would just blast you with like one
or one or two single shots.
But that was way more effective in mma.
Like the explosive really fast style.
Yeah.
I never thought I would like to see a,
uh,
a wonderboy,
one of his kickboxing fights and he was
like,
like $57 a kickbox and I never watched
him kickbox online.
You can see them online.
I should do that online because God
knows what I'm doing.
It's not helping me getting off.
So yeah,
I'm trying not to as much,
but it's like there's so many fun things
to watch.
I've been think jerking off during the
day because I,
it's so ritualistic for me that when I
jerk off during the day I'm like,
ah,
okay,
I can be a person and I don't have to
think about that for the rest of the
day.
It really helps my day go much more
productive.
Have you ever taught a meditating?
Do you meditate at all?
No,
I get it like,
you know,
uh,
before the,
the,
uh,
we started joe pointed.
He's like,
you always have an issue and he's right
and that's like for me it will be an
itch.
What you were talking about some new
issue with my throat,
but I had that for years.
We're starting certain foods fucked me
up if that happens to me too though.
Pot does that for sure.
Really?
Yeah,
we smoke too much weed before a show.
I'll get Flemmi.
I think it's a combination of many
coffee and eggs,
like the eggs,
I think do it.
I went to one of these alternative
doctors.
I thought maybe my,
uh,
my uh,
adrenal,
adrenal glands were fucked up.
So he's like,
well you got to cut out the eggs or cut
out the coffee and I can't stop with the
krave.
Fruit's good for before a show like
apples,
you know,
certain flux behind it.
I went around the corner.
I had one of those veggie thing,
a pure vegetable juice,
splitly,
celery and a fucking vegetable just
blows because it just dominates the
entire juice.
I hate it.
It's great for cleaning out.
Your system isn't really good for you.
Oh,
throws your fucking pipes free.
Like celery juice is one of the best
juices.
Like if you have to take a shit,
you know,
I've been constipated except on a new
medication that's supposed to cause
diarrhea and I have been,
I have not been shitting and I'm usually
waiting on a medication for.
I just want to call it,
prep it so you don't get HIV and I'm
negative.
I know,
but I need it now because I'm in a
fucking relationship.
But I started to take it.
I'm like,
I'm just going to be smart because I'm a
fucking smart to take a medication like
that.
Like isn't,
aren't there like AIDS medications now?
HIV medications are like completely stop
it from there are,
but you don't want to have it.
I don't want to get it.
Yeah.
I mean I think I've only taken it for a
little while and I'm probably going stop
because I'm in the relationship and I
got to go.
They want you to be tested after a month
and make sure that your blood is okay.
Get livers.
Okay.
Your kidneys,
they want to look you over.
Yeah.
Again,
off that shit.
Is it bad for you?
I just got to imagine it is.
Anything that.
I mean,
anything that gives you diarrhea?
Well it's only for a few days but it
didn't give it to me.
It literally stopped me from shitting.
Constipation.
It did.
Yeah,
it did.
Yeah.
I just,
uh,
I mean,
isn't that a thing with like vicodin and
a lot of those pain killers?
It gives you constipation?
Yeah.
I've only taken vicodin once,
after I had my sinuses fixed,
but the side,
that prep I took it.
I don't have any more than that.
I like,
I'm going to go back and see the guy and
again,
I don't even know if I'm gonna to do it
again and take that shit.
I just want.
I was one point I was being crazy,
so I'm like,
I just want to make sure I don't get
that.
Yeah,
you know,
I would rather have some kind of a kid.
I knew I wouldn't be on it forever,
but I'm like,
while I'm fucking acting like an ass,
let me at least one of the podcast
episodes that I took the most amount of
heat for early in the day was I did a
podcast with a guy named Peter Duesberg.
He's a biologist at the University of
California Berkeley,
and he's a very respected biologist
who's done a lot of great work on
cancer,
but he's got a very controversial take
on HIV and he does not believe that HIV
causes AIDS.
He thinks that HIV is evidence of a weak
immune system.
Excuse me.
And he thinks that when people have HIV,
it's because their immune system is
compromised.
It's not that HIV compromises their
immune system.
Oh,
okay.
And he feels like all these people that
are catching aids and getting,
uh,
HIV,
what's happening is they're doing a lot
of party drugs,
they're doing emile and crystal
meth and that's very,
very prevalent inside the gay community,
you know,
gay guys party a ton,
right?
And they're,
they're doing a lot of drugs and he
points to the high correlation between
all these people doing these party drugs
and HIV.
His work is widely criticized amongst
legitimate scientists and most people
just do not agree with him.
And they said that the,
um,
the connection between HIV and AIDS is
rock solid and undeniable.
But he thinks it's not in.
It's an boy.
Did people get mad at me about that one?
I'm,
I'm just talking to this guy who's a
biologist at the University of
California,
Berkeley.
I mean,
I'm figuring this guy's legit scientist,
but he can't get funding for anything.
He's essentially blackballed from the
academic community.
And it was really weird talking to them.
It's like,
has anybody debated you?
And he's like,
no,
no one will debate me.
You know,
is it,
is it almost like,
um,
what about Arthur Ashe?
Or is he saying that a direct injection
into the bloodstream will give it to
you?
How does he explain those?
Well,
I don't know what Arthur Ashe was doing,
but what he was saying essentially was
that transfusion.
I think you got it.
One of the things about HIV was if you
got HIV,
Arthur Ashe got a transfusion.
For what reason though?
Oh,
I don't know.
I'm not your thing.
He had something wrong.
Right?
When what he's saying is that when your
immune system is compromised,
that's when HIV shows itself that HIV is
a very weak virus and that it only shows
up in the immune systems of people that
are compromised and that.
Is he saying we all have it or you can
catch it like,
no,
he's not saying we all have it,
but you saying you can catch it,
but he's saying the evidence of it is
only in people that have a weakened
immune system.
Again,
I'm just not something I believe in.
Gentlemen.
Don't get mad at me because I'm white or
you know,
there's so many.
I think there's a million different
cases of people who obviously were,
you know,
who got it in in very weird ways are
again,
two blood transfusions or they were born
with it.
But here it says,
Arthur ash says he believed he
contracted HIV,
the virus that causes AIDS through a
transfusion of tainted blood during his
second round of heart bypass surgery in
1983.
First learned of his inspection.
Now here's the other issue that I'm
Peter Duesberg was saying was that what
they were giving people when they first
tested positive for HIV was act.
That act is a medication they used to
use for chemotherapy,
but they stopped using it for
chemotherapy because it was killing
people quicker than cancer was killing
people.
I mean,
it was just a brutal,
brutal drug and they had a bunch of it
in his mind.
They had a bunch of it laying around
after that and they decided to try to
use it on aids patients and they started
reading re,
uh,
in,
you know,
reintroducing it and you wonder.
I guess the conspiracy thing is I take
pharmaceuticals.
We had all these drugs and they wanted
to get rid of unneeded or do they think
that hey,
they were just trying to do something
else.
I mean,
obviously it wasn't the smart thing to
do because they don't use it anymore and
it didn't help people act did not help
people with aids.
I mean,
people who took azt died,
lot of them,
shitload
of them and aids back then was
essentially a death sentence,
but there was a lot of people that
didn't do anything that got aids that
got HIV.
It never got aids.
They just took care of their body and it
took a holistic approach and using
nutrition.
And I,
I just think it's super controversial,
like anything else.
I mean there's people that get cancer
and don't die.
They get cured of it.
Sure.
But then there's people that get cancer
at ravages are system and kills them.
So Steve Jobs,
I mean,
he listened to people.
I think he didn't try like alternative
met Steve Jobs should still be alive.
He had,
like they said,
a pretty curable form of cancer.
You can get pancreatic.
Uh,
no.
I thought he,
I thought his was,
they said a fairly curable one,
that he had listened to his friends and
tried to go so holistic and they said if
he had gone and just had it treated,
he probably would've survived it.
Well,
those was probably a lot of that going
on.
There's always a lot of fucking wacky
people with their wacky ideas about
holistic medicine.
Did.
I saw a guy do a ted talk on basically
saying like strawberries are really good
because they caused other anti
angiogenesis or something,
which is about.
It stops the production of new blood
vessels and that's what feeds cancer.
Like he had this.
He literally had me convinced you could
eat fucking strawberries and I kicked
cancer in large quantities.
So I mean if you hear somebody talk who
really knows what they're talking about,
even if they're wrong,
a lot of people are convinced by.
Well that's one of the problems with
like youtube videos,
right?
Where people have wacky conspiracy
theories as long as they speak with big
words and I say things in complete
sentences and they sound articulate.
You start to believe them.
Don't.
The one thing that has been proven to be
effective with cancer,
some forms of cancer is ketogenic diets.
Diets where your fat based,
where you eat a lot of Avocados and
coconut oil and your body Burns those
rather than glucose and some cancers
feed off sugar,
so to starve them,
you go on a very low sugar diet and a
very high fat diet and apparently
there's real science that shows that
there's some benefits to that,
but so there's only certain kinds of
cancers,
certain kinds of cancers.
It doesn't affect at all.
Certain kinds of brain cancers.
It doesn't affect it all.
It doesn't matter what the fuck you do.
You better go to a doctor.
Yeah,
I mean he can do both.
We want it to go to the doctor and try
some of that,
like having another coddling under the
fucking hospital.
You have to choose what we about to say.
Jamie,
what I just googled on the Steve Jobs
thing is like both of you are actually
correct from what I just found that he
had pancreatic cancer,
but he also could have been saved
potentially,
but then the next thing also says that,
uh,
he lived for 20 years with it.
So,
uh,
he didn't have chemo or radiation.
They,
uh,
swayze a pancreatic and died within 18
months.
Oh,
they're saying that the,
the,
uh,
the treatment killed him or are there
different kinds of pancreatic cancers?
Stupid.
Lately it isn't there.
There's a Hodgkin's and non Hodgkin's
lymphoma one is worse than the other,
but that bag up please Jesus Christ and
said,
Steve Lived for 20 years of this cancer.
It seems he did not have chemotherapy or
radiation treatment at all.
The Hollywood actors who's at answering
this?
This is what is this,
this bullshit?
See,
by the way out,
go up there right there.
Walter Isaacson,
he's writing the Steve Jobs biography.
He told 60 minutes that Steve refused
what could have been potentially a
lifesaving surgery,
but he did have more than one surgery,
right?
Didn't he have his liver replaced?
Whereas I feel like he had a liver
transplant.
What is it that makes a guy not want to
surgery?
That might work,
like do people become delusional in that
they're that or are they afraid of the
surgery?
Are they willing to die?
Like fucking Zappa hated going to the
doctor and he died lose he 56.
What was wrong with Zappa when he.
It was a cancer I want.
I was just calling cancer or prostate.
The surgeon who gave Steve jobs a new
liver and two more years faces new
questions.
That's a 2013.
What does it say?
It says he bought the Memphis House with
job convalesced.
What?
He later bought the Memphis House.
He bought the house where Steve Jobs was
living there.
They said the guy who was treating
George Harrison board on guitar to sign
while he was in the fucking hospital.
Sign this real quick.
Yeah.
Revelation came with the end of the
southern transplant Mark Buba Bulls.
Say that name.
Peruse squeak per,
per uh,
weight a rescue pressq ,
a Poreska Presca front page story.
Rewey R,
r u,
S Q,
u I n a front page story Thursday in the
Memphis commercial advocate piece paints
a vivid picture of the life saving
operation,
although it takes most of the details
about jobs from the Walter Isaacson
biography and blah,
blah,
blah.
So why,
what is the question?
How did jobs move to the top of the
list?
Oh,
it's one of those things.
It's like Frank Underwood and the
fucking.
Yeah,
why don't we probably paid somebody.
Jesus,
how the fuck do you think he gets to the
top of the list when you have $50,
million dollars you can move around yet
when the way you are emailing is because
of something you've invented,
you'd probably get to the fucking top of
the list.
Fast wonder what killed his liver.
I wonder if it was medication,
like medication for.
I know a friend who just died from
pancreatic cancer and he had it for
quite a few years.
I met him.
I met him in 2014 and he already had it
and he just died.
It says he uh,
refused.
Tim Cook's liver transplant offer
because he has the same rare blood type
of Sim.
Wow.
Whoa.
Tim Cook would have given Steve Jobs or
a chunk of liver boy.
That's tense than anyone's ever taken
over the company.
Hey,
whoa.
Yeah.
What are you must have been?
If you want to give you a moisture
liver,
I wouldn't get my boss a hat.
Yeah.
Could you.
I guess the.
Obviously they were good friends.
Can you imagine?
That's intense,
man.
Your liver is something that regenerates
hospital where jobs received transplant
was given $40,000,000
by him.
Wow.
That's how you do it.
Yeah.
I guess he was appreciated.
Let's look.
That's how you get to the front of the
line.
What do you think the lines are supposed
to be?
Fair.
You fucks.
This is a way to cut 40 million,
40 million declan cut.
Yeah.
You give some money to the hospital.
It's probably going to save a shitload
of lives.
We went to before you came.
Here we are at my.
My radio agent died of cancer.
He was like 64,
65.
It was not that old and he had a cancer
of the lymph nodes and he fucking was
getting a little bit better,
we thought and then went for surgery for
circulation between these people in
these super high stress jobs like
agents.
It can because I know stress by Bob was
not as stressed guy though,
unless he swallowed all that.
He was a very calm guy.
Like literally he was gentle and he gave
you bad news gently but firmly.
Um,
he was a very,
very unique guy.
He was not stressed and less.
He swallowed it and never showed it,
but he,
he seemed like a very zen guy.
Um,
and it was something with his,
uh,
went in for a breathing thing and just
died.
I guess I'm definitely on the table and
I don't have the details.
Fuck man.
But yeah,
he was not that old.
I mean it was 64 when you have.
I'm 49,
so when you just,
almost 60 foil,
that's fucking,
that's a,
a graspable age.
I wonder like,
you know,
obviously there's so many different
factors that play into like the
lifespan,
the difference between lifespans today.
Life Spans 100 years ago,
200 years ago,
and obviously there's been some big
advances in medicine,
but I wonder like how much our diet
plays on the,
the amount of cancer.
I mean it's kind of a huge factor.
All his sugar,
all the bullshit people eat all the
preservatives,
smoking,
pollution.
They say that just living in a city can
take up to 10 years off your life.
That's also probably like,
it's probably the air and it's probably,
it's probably the stress too because
people in the city or just stressed.
Yeah,
I'm sure all that stuff goes into it.
I mean we try to avoid it,
but I try to eat healthy like grilled
chicken,
but a fun one.
I never took into consideration until
just a couple of years ago.
I read an article on the effects of
brake dust.
Like when you're around a high
population area and people constantly
hitting their brakes.
Really?
Yeah.
When you're in traffic all the time,
those breaks when you,
you know,
you're cleaning your wheels and you get
that break shit all over your wheels.
Sure.
That stuff's in the air.
That black sooty shit.
That shit gets in the air and if you're
in a place like say if you're in
Manhattan and you got like a second
floor,
walk up your windows open,
you're just taking in breakdown.
You're breathing that in all the time.
He'll wipe it off your fucking furniture
and shit.
You'll,
you'll see it on your table.
It's something that never,
no one ever thinks I'd be there.
Like I've never heard anyone discuss
brake dust,
but it is something that's all over the
place.
Well we find dust back there jamie.
Like what is that dust that we keep
finding back there?
It's all black.
It's probably just like La dirts because
it's dry and dusty around,
but it's black that I see it in my house
too,
but I mean back there,
it's weird because we have a closed
garage door just comes in under the air.
We have this workout equipment and when
we wiped the workout equipment,
like if we go back there right now and
put a wet paper towel to that,
a reverse hyper machine,
the top event,
it's all black,
like black dust.
Wait,
there's stuff behind that.
Yeah.
There's a whole warehouse back.
As many times I've been this room,
I thought this was the entire room.
I had no idea what a cool fucking
sectional that is dead.
There's a room back there and there's
another room behind it.
Oh,
okay.
Scientists find new ways of freeways are
trying to kill you.
What is it saying that the thickening
progressing twice,
the average in people living within 100
meters of a freeway,
the connection between particulate
matter and artery thickening were
statistically significant for some
groups.
Yeah.
That's what they're talking about.
That's brake dust and shit that's coming
out of exhaust pipes according to La
Times.
One point 5 million people live within
300 meters of a freeway and the La
Basin.
Last year we found out the freeway
pollution travels much further than
that.
As much as 2000,
500 meters from the source.
Fuck all that,
so if you're now I wonder if it's the
same in Manhattan.
I'm sure it is,
but.
Or maybe because Manhattan has already
play.
Have a lot less cars going by your
street and Manhattan than you do.
They're 2,500
meters as far.
How far is that in like feet or miles?
Is that a mile?
A mile?
A mile or kilometer?
That's two and a half kilometers.
That's fucked man.
Everybody a mile from the highways
getting poisoned.
Jesus,
you'll hope it,
but how old is that studying?
Is it still happening as much like our.
Our break,
our breaks made me better now than they
were a few years ago.
That's the same thing.
No,
the same thing.
Those 2010 breaks at the same.
I mean there,
there's no different.
They,
they're,
they're the same fucking things.
They've always had these pads.
They press down,
they were out.
You got to replace them and when they're
wearing out there grinding down,
that powder isn't going anywhere.
Right?
Someone should probably figure out a way
how to contain that mean.
That seems like what we're doing now is
it just,
it just goes out into the atmosphere.
Maybe they should be contained,
like where the powder,
the brakes would work the same way,
but the powder would have to be like
sucked up into some sort of a pouch or
something and you have to change it like
a filter.
How often would you have to change it?
Probably all the time,
but that seems like that would be like a
real viable alternative,
like some sort of encased break thing.
You know what I mean?
That doesn't seem like outside of the
realm of engineering,
what can they make the breaks,
if that sounds unfeasible,
can they make the breaks out of
something that's actually just not as
bad for you?
Is there anything they can do that might
be a little bit of a fix,
but I think anything you breathe in,
you breathe in Sawdust and sucks for
you.
It's a particulate matter like you're
taking in things and you're taking a
certain kind of dust into your lungs and
it becomes an irritant,
so it's not good.
Not good,
Jamie.
Wow.
A sad,
sad for all those people that live near
the highway.
Well,
they live near the highway and I have my
lifestyle,
so I guess we're all going to fucking
dropped that a little earlier than we
showed this.
And you don't have HIV.
No.
Keep a rubber on.
You're going to be fine.
Don't anybody come in your butt and
everything's gonna be okay.
It's just fucking what a party killer.
I know I've got a lot of rules,
but no condoms.
No,
I can't wear them.
Oh,
well that's going to be a problem.
It's definitely a problem.
My fucking Dick shrivels.
How many guys have gotten aids from
regular sex though?
Probably very few.
Very few probably,
but should have it.
I'm sure.
I'm sure it's somehow physically
possible,
but you probably have to have so many
things lined up to get it from fucking
pussy or even fucking ass.
You have to have so many things.
I'm sure it can happen though.
Yeah,
well it's.
It's the issue is it has to get into
your body,
but I know that people get sick all the
time from having a cut and then I'm
getting someone's blood in their cuts,
like that's happened to people in
hospitals that have done surgery and cut
their finger while they're doing it and
they get infected by the blood of
someone else.
That's common.
Right.
So it's got a little cut on your Dick.
I remember when I had that thought,
I've told the story of Hbo Special.
I had three similar Ron Jeremy after the
porn awards.
It was,
yeah.
Was.
It was fun.
It didn't feel necessarily sexy,
but it was fun.
Yeah,
it was just.
it was a Goof,
you know,
it's like a girl and he's fucking her.
So he went into the bathroom.
He was fucking one girl and he fucked
another one and he,
I remember he put rubbing alcohol around
his dick and I don't know if that's that
good for you,
but I think he was doing to make sure he
didn't have a cut,
but he only did that before he fucked
her.
I think.
I think alcohol or something.
Yeah,
to make sure that it was cleaning the
window.
Cut set is so hard core.
It is.
But you know,
his Dick has probably seen a lot of
action and it might be a way to keep
things off it.
Yeah.
If that guy doesn't have aids,
who the fuck is getting aids?
You know about that.
You're not lucky.
I'm a lucky guy.
Lucky.
Terrible now.
Yeah.
I mean think about that.
If that guy doesn't have aids,
fuck yeah.
I mean I do realize I've rolled the dice
way too many times and I'm like,
I'm lucky that I'm really grateful.
Like a fuck man.
You just stop.
Well it's also your uh,
you know,
it's just think it's harder to get like
for a man than it is for a woman it
seems like unless again,
you let somebody come in here,
but yeah,
that can be harder.
I think it's harder to get,
but he didn't know.
What am I at Dr.
No,
but you're right.
I think it is hard.
It's hard to go fuck without a rubber
right now because Rogan.
Tessa.
No,
but I think you're right.
It probably is harder to get unless you
have a cut on your Dick and she's
cutting her pussy and they happen to
just go air tight against each other.
I mean,
come on.
Yeah.
For a woman like you gotta,
think like all there,
everything's exposed,
right?
All that area inside their vagina is all
open tissue.
Right.
It's all like absorbing like they have
the worst situation set up,
but I think the air.
I was told years ago by a woman who
worked in the health field that it's
such a.
it's such a delicate virus that if you
like,
she's like a blow job.
You won't even get it from.
She's like,
because you're,
your stomach kills the semen.
She's like,
you.
You can even give him a blow job.
Which I don't know how true that is,
but she called me that fucking.
She lives in Elkton,
Maryland.
I remember she was a really cute girl.
I met at a road gig.
I remember the fucking town she lived
in.
She was telling you this before.
She blew you and don't worry about it.
Yeah,
don't worry about it.
Stomach acid.
Swatch glow.
Yeah,
she was really,
she was a wonderful health practitioner.
She's fucking drink about a gallon of
seeds and tell me we're all going to be
fine.
Elkton Maryland.
Good girl.
Isn't it crazy though that so many
diseases kill people from sex?
You mean syphilis,
gonorrhea,
those are those fatal without,
you know,
like that's isn't syphilis would killed
Al Capone?
Um,
I think so.
Yeah.
I believe we even did,
but in the twenties there was nothing
they could do for.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
But I mean,
it's just amazing that untreated so many
diseases turned me.
Think about how few things other than
like severely compromised immune systems
that get hit by the flu.
You know,
the people that die from the flu,
usually it's old people or young really
young people that are kind of frail.
They wind up getting sick and dying from
common colds and things along those
lines.
But most people they get better from it.
Can you imagine shooting cancer out of
your Dick?
If for that was like fucking a,
that would be like,
that's where we have a problem.
If you could,
if you could give somebody cancer
sexually,
and I know they say oral sex and throat
cancers possible,
well HPV,
human papilloma virus can give some
women ovarian cancer or you can get it
in your throat if they have it from
eating pussy.
Well,
isn't that what the Michael Douglas
thing was?
They said that fucking Catherine Zeta
Jones put the Kibosh on that rubber.
She was like not true.
Plus we're getting a divorce.
Oh yeah,
man.
She must have been when he was.
He went out and started talking about
that and they're like looking at her
pussy.
That must have been so annoying.
You know Michael Throat cancer and oral
sex photo of him.
If I get.
If you google throat cancer and oral
sex,
Michael Douglas comes up.
That's got to be a bummer.
Yeah,
so he could probably should have kept
his mouth shut about that,
but she did.
She was like,
it.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but wasn't she suffering from some
serious mental illness,
like some,
some ruthless bipolar type shit?
No,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I think Catherine Zeta Jones is pretty
open about mental illness.
I didn't know she was.
It's not surprising that somebody that
hot like there's always a price to pay.
Yeah,
there's always,
you know,
you date someone that beautiful that her
now her private struggle struggle.
Catherine Zeta Jones bipolar disorder.
Well,
you know it's true because it's in
people celebrity.
Yeah.
They always get to the bottom of post.
Yeah,
she's too hot.
That's the problem.
Nature just gives her a fucking curve
ball.
Know you want to be hot.
How bout a little crazy to be this
beautiful and you're gonna.
Want to hang yourself during a second
commercial.
Here you go.
Fucking get this.
She says,
I torture.
My husband had a tough few years from
her husband's cancer to and public
battled bipolar disorder.
Now the Hollywood stars back with a new
film and film.
Not,
not really new article because she's
kind of vanished off the face of the
map.
Yeah.
You gotta wonder like when people.
There's.
I was looking at some pictures the other
day of a,
some movie star that I forgot who his
name was,
but he was in a ton of movies and that.
Oh,
the guy that was in platoon with scars
all over his face.
Tom Berenger,
and then just finished.
You know what he kinda did man,
and I don't know why he did a couple.
We have been a school teacher.
There's nothing worse than the white
school teacher in the black school.
We get it.
We get at.
You're rescuing them fucking Hollywood
assholes.
Michelle pfeiffer and how great was she
in dangerous minds mentally?
Gangster's paradise was the theme song
and she was going to go in there and
with that bad accent and she was.
It was funny.
She was.
This is why
people feeling like their music was
getting lame where I think it was Bob
Dylan lyrics she was teaching the young
roughy ins with.
That's like desperate white people
wanting to go like,
look,
black guys.
Our stuff's cool,
and they read the lyrics.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
These are troubled times.
You don't fucking luck.
That was strong as I could be.
That's what it is.
They can.
We check that.
If it was a bucket,
Dylan's over.
Shoot a homeboy.
Oh my God.
She wrote that down on.
Who should you shoot,
Catherine?
Her fucking handle.
She looks like Gilbert grape with that
heritage.
She was really hot,
but not in that one.
Yeah,
and she had a leather jacket on the
show.
She was hard for even indoors.
Who wears a leather jacket?
She was not.
Her accent was not good gangster.
What was the accent?
It was southern,
but it kind of went back and forth.
Know she was from Tennessee or fucking
word Boston.
When they keep.
I think they make a decision one day.
The first day of shooting is 40 minutes
into the film,
Forty minutes off you go deep into the
movie.
That's the first day of shooting and
then they start somewhere else.
They changed the accident and it just
changes by the time they get the 40
minutes in the elevator picture of her
with coolio.
Coolio.
One fear factor.
Did he really?
Yeah,
and he was so high.
I mean so high.
I would open up his trailer door and
just get a fucking ferocious contact
high just from opening the door.
I was like,
what?
I A Canadian guy.
Well,
I don't.
I don't know.
I did.
What you would call it,
Mark Marin had a show called,
nevermind the buzzcocks and one of the
guests on there was coolio when I did
with Monday wonder Mike from the
sugarhill gang.
Coolio.
Nevermind the buzzcocks might.
Yeah,
Mark Marin.
It was a British show and Mark Marin
hosted it here in late 2000 and he was
one of the guests that uh,
and he,
he loved me.
We had so much fun and I saw him years
later and he had no memory that we'd
ever met.
So he did.
He loved it.
He literally,
I told him he literally gotten the knees
and was bowing to mix.
I said something fucked up.
So he was just enjoying it.
So I'm like,
the guy will definitely remember me,
like fucking dumb slick rick.
I brought him on stage at the comedy
cellar one time we took a photo
together.
I saw him years later in the airport,
nothing like,
how do you not remember being on board
on the stage from the audience if I was
watching a show and they brought me up
on stage,
man,
he was like,
Dylan picture.
So a lot of those guys and meet,
they meet so many people that they're,
they're hard drivers is constantly full.
They're just constantly deleting files,
which is understandable.
It was just the circumstances that were
weird,
like not,
not the fact that it was like me,
like I've interviewed people and they
don't remember me,
but I get that because I've done radio
shows and I don't know who the fuck you
are 10 minutes later.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You and slick rick at the,
one of my favorite photos in history,
he was in the audience and none of the
comedians would talk to them,
so I was going to always tell them I
loved them and I'm like,
I'm taking a photo with you after the
show.
And Manny and the owner was in there and
he goes,
oh man,
he was so great and so fucking
ridiculous.
Did he get shot in the eye or something?
I don't know how he's.
I believe he got shot or he did
something like that was in a children's
story.
Like there was something similar in his
real life when you went to jail like
that,
that rapid children's.
Um,
but I don't know exactly how he's
island.
I thought maybe he,
I thought he had an interesting story
for that,
but maybe he didn't.
I interviewed coolio before he won fear
factor and the last 31 he was telling me
that this is already over.
He's already done this.
He's lived a thousand lives and a
thousand universes and he was just so
barbecued.
It was like inspirational.
Wow.
Was I was listening to him.
I was like Whoa.
But because he was so high,
like I think it just had no nerves going
in.
He just sort of did the event.
Like it was nothing on afraid.
Yeah.
Completely have some balance thing.
I forget what it is.
They were on some beams or some shit.
So fucking amazing.
Nobody died doing that show.
I look back at it sometimes and I just
go,
Ooh,
like do it again with another host.
Yeah.
With a ludicrous.
That's right.
Ludicrous is doing it.
They did it once.
I don't know if they're gonna keep doing
it.
Apparently it was kind of a flop.
What does it mean you don't want to?
Because when it was done it was very
timely,
but now with the Internet has gotten so
much faster and we can watch everything
on our phone.
It's kind of like you could see real
life deaths.
Yeah.
So it's Kinda hard to see people doing
crazy stuff when you can turn it on and
just see someone do it without a shell
around.
They just doing it.
Well.
It's also the did it without the
original production team and the
original production team,
they,
they cut the budget substantially so it
looked kind of cheap.
And then the Stents,
warren is dangerous.
Like the original production team,
they were wizards.
I mean they were really good at that
kind of show and they did 148 episodes
of the first season and then we came
back.
We did six more.
So there was a.
I mean they had just massive amounts of
experience and putting together like the
stunt people,
the stunt people,
beast on.
It's where all the gross things,
like all that stuff was.
I think they didn't do any gross stuff
this time around.
The lawyers got involved.
They probably now is corporate.
The lawyers will quietly,
you know,
and then they were like worried about
lawsuits in no matter what you signed,
they're still going to do.
So the lawyer probably chopped lot lie
that shit out or they couldn't get
insurance.
Well with NBC,
the second interrail iteration of fear
factor and be like,
what was it,
like 2012 or something like that.
And we did it again.
Two Thousand Eleven,
2012 when we did it again.
They were often,
I think it was 11.
They did it.
It was off the deep end.
Scary.
Like they went way too far.
Yeah,
it was dangerous.
I thought it was dangerous.
Like some of the stuff they were doing,
we're like so much more intense than the
stuff that we'd done before.
I'm like,
this is fucking.
We could.
Someone could get hurt here.
Did you not want to do it after that?
A second season of the new iteration.
And you said when do it?
Well,
they canceled it because people had a
drink.
Come.
Why that should have automatically got
to the second season.
That's what got to cancel.
They play.
They played horseshoes for donkey come.
Yeah.
They were throwing horseshoes and in no
matter what you had to drink.
Some come like if you landed a perfect
ring toss and then you only had a drink
that a couple of ounces.
But these drinks,
these dudes were drinking beer steins
have come.
Wow.
Why they can't with his complaints or
the network go.
They went too far.
I'm TMZ got
ahold of footage and they put an NBC
passed on.
I mean they,
they,
they passed.
They said okay to all these guns.
Right.
So they,
they,
they cleared all of the ridiculous
stunts that they wanted to do and this
was the most ridiculous.
Like getting people to drink,
come on television.
Yeah,
that's rough.
Well,
it was just like,
it's so over the top and that's the idea
was that they couldn't have fear factor
the way they used to have it before they
had to be.
It had to be bigger,
badder,
crazier a fear factor.
And so the second version of it was just
completely over the top,
a little too much and they pushed it too
far and too gross people out.
Yeah.
They drank donkey pis and donkey come
and it was twins.
So one twin had a drink.
The Pis,
she's drinking piss and the other girls
drink come.
Wow.
Mug a Mug of coffee.
Oh my God,
what a great girlfriend.
She must be though.
Fucking ace.
You know what's interesting?
A lot of the girls wanted a drink to
come rather than drink the pice.
Of course they have experienced with it.
They,
they,
the pisses a grocer thing come.
They're like,
all right,
come.
It's not great,
but I've drank it and that guy drank.
Come and look at it.
They're hugging.
They've got on their shirts.
It was deep,
man.
There's only been two times ever in the
history of the show where I said to the
producers,
Hey,
don't don't do this.
And that was one of them.
You said they shouldn't do it.
I said,
it's too much.
It's just too crazy.
Oh my God.
That's a lot of calm.
The shot.
Come look at her,
chugging it down.
Oh my God,
Amanda and chugging a town with me.
My fucking stupid big head hovering over
you telling you to do.
You were encouraging her to do anything.
It's like,
you know,
I mean I wanted her to win.
I wanted,
I wanted them all to win.
It's part of the problem with doing that
show.
You liked them?
Well,
yeah.
I mean hopefully you wanted people to,
to,
you know,
I was like a coach or a motivational
speaker as much as I was telling him you
can do it.
Why did you get in their head?
And you just tell them like,
look,
you just put one foot in front of the
other and just don't,
don't entertain any thoughts of quitting
because a lot of quitting is just in
your mind.
A lot of quitting is just your mind
saying,
man,
we can't do this,
man.
We should find a way out,
Fuck this.
This is just too uncomfortable.
Whereas if you can just force yourself
to push those aside and don't entertain
those thoughts at all,
you can get through a lot of things.
You can't get through.
Yeah.
That's the hard part is when you start
telling us.
It's almost when people push themselves.
I remember Matt Serra was actually
talking about Ray Longo and the way
he'll push you past what you think you
can go,
but my problem is I'll stop,
but I think I have to stop,
but I guess there is this stuff in the
reserve tank,
but it just feels like there's nothing
there,
but it's a mind set.
It's like if you get your mind
accustomed to convincing your body,
the enough is enough and then you start
entertaining those thoughts and thinking
of those thoughts more than thinking
about concentrating on the task at hand.
You start thinking about,
boy,
if I just quit now,
I can quit all this uncomfortable
feeling will stop all this.
A heaving of my breath or burning of my
legs or whatever it is that you're
doing.
That can all stop.
All the nervousness can stop.
Like you see a lot of times before
fights.
Um,
we've had several instances over the
course of the history of the UFC.
Most of the time it doesn't happen,
but several incidents where people get
anxiety attacks and you could attribute
that to a lot of different things,
right?
You could say,
well,
some people just have anxiety and well,
what is an anxiety attack?
Well,
some people believe that a lot of what's
happening is the mindset that you're
entering into a fight with and that
you're allowing your mind to just sort
of run rampant rather than corralling it
and channeling your mind into very
distinct pathways like very distinct
pathways of only beneficial thoughts and
you will vacillate and deviate from
those thoughts,
but always bring it back to those very
important thoughts and to have some sort
of a mantra like you are here to do your
very best.
That's it.
And all thoughts of quitting.
If your body fails on you,
that's one thing,
but let it fail.
Don't,
don't,
don't entertain those thoughts.
Oh my God,
now it's time to quit.
Don't quit,
don't quit.
Don't entertain those thoughts.
And there's a guy named David Goggins
we've talked about on the podcast almost
too much,
but he's a very famous endurance athlete
who's a,
um,
things navy seal and he,
uh,
has the world record for the most amount
of Chin ups in a day and you know,
some insane amount.
Right?
He's doing,
he will do sets of five where he does
five Chin ups and he does them over the
course.
It was over a thousand.
Right.
But he does way more than it was 2000.
Yeah.
That way it doesn't burn his arms out
and,
but how long they take taken between
fillon and it takes a little break,
you know,
do five,
take a little break,
relax a little,
do another five,
take a little break,
relax a little bit back again.
And he's,
he attempted it more than once because
one time we did it as a forum tour.
Thousand and 12.
My God.
Yeah.
So that guy,
one of his statements is most people
quit it 40 percent.
Most people quit at 40 percent of what
they're capable of.
Really?
Yeah.
And I think that's absolutely accurate.
I,
um,
I think about that all the time.
I think about all the time when I'm on a
hard run,
you got to know when you're running like
hills and particularly got to know when
you're just fucking exhausted and you're
running the risk of falling down and you
really can't breathe right?
Like you're,
you're really pushing it because
particularly things like sprints or hill
sprints,
you will reach an aerobic threshold.
You'll reach a place where like,
you really can't go any further.
You're,
your heartbeat is 185 beats a minute.
You can't do it.
Yeah,
you're,
you're blowing your shit out.
I mean,
you're going to fail.
But like when is it failing and when are
you quitting?
Because there's some uncomfortable
moments where my heart's like 150,
a hundred 60,
where if I was feeling like a pussy,
I'm like,
let me just take a break here and
breathe,
you know,
which is what Bert Kreischer does.
Yeah,
he probably has.
It's a lot of.
It's mental.
So you think he's just quitting?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's fine.
Dot you though,
because you feel like your is telling
you like I'm on the treadmill,
I can't do much.
Like Ah,
exactly.
Can't do it.
It's fucking boring too.
That's why I like running outside.
I don't like running.
I think running on a treadmill would be
great if you had a fucking awesome movie
in front of you.
Say if you were watching platoon and
you're running on a treadmill and it's
right in front of you or apocalypse now
and you're listening to it.
Yeah,
I mean you can get into it,
but I like running outside because I
know where I'm going and it's part of
the goal.
Like I,
if I reached this peak,
that means it's a mild one point six
miles and then another one point six
back.
Can you run farther in real life or on a
treadmill?
I don't run on treadmills.
Are you?
But if you had to like,
wait,
which one could you do a more on a trip?
You can.
Oh,
for sure.
100.
First of all,
the way I run,
I'm running all hills.
Like I don't really run flat when I'm
running flats for very short periods of
time.
It's only flat in between hills.
Uh,
I fucking hate hills there.
They're terrible.
But here's the thing,
I kickbox box yesterday for the first
time in months I hadn't done any,
any pad work,
any bag work,
anything like that.
And I was going through rounds,
like it was nothing.
It was crazy.
Like it was so different than cardio is
better.
Oh my cardio's way better just from
running these hills because I do it.
I'm committed to doing it twice a week.
I try to do it three times a week,
but I'm committed to doing it twice a
week.
So I did it today and I did it Monday.
How long does it take you to run the
hills and our,
my workouts and our.
Okay.
It was fucking brutal dude at the end of
last several pounds of water completely
exhausted and drained.
But when I do other stuff I have way
more endurance and I feel great after
like right now,
like I'm so relaxed,
like after that happens,
you just feel so good.
Like you feel like,
like regular life is not as,
it's just not as hard because the
running is so difficult.
I should try that.
You know,
I fucking hate running so much but I'm
so bored in the gym.
But you live in Manhattan,
but there's still the park.
I mean it's kind of,
there's this little place that you could
run them but you're not running,
you know,
you know what you should do.
I mean that's nothing.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I mean running is definitely a good
thing as long as you're doing it the
right way and running on the balls of
your feet and not on the heel and.
But try to take in yoga.
You know,
I like Yoga.
I like women with Yoga bodies that
fucking long,
like long lean,
like thorax.
It's a sexy look at a walmart or acts
like they,
they just have like a,
like an insect body almost.
It's long and Lincoln sex.
What's that?
Are you into bugs?
No,
but that's the best way I can compare
them.
I've had bugs on me.
I don't care for them three times.
Are you a book?
Kutcher,
uh,
no,
those guys are crazy,
man.
Fuck yeah,
they actually almost want it.
Yeah,
they do want,
they want it.
I think it's pressure.
Tell people what we're talking about.
Bug catchers are guys I've only heard of
being gay guy.
Maybe the straight guys just do it,
but they'll go out and fuck guys trying
to catch HIV or let guys fuck them.
Let guys fuck that.
Yeah.
I mean like guys fuck them to catch HIV.
Like they really,
they want it.
Um,
and I,
I personally think it's because then the
pressure is off.
Um,
that's my guess.
I don't comprehend it.
Think it's a self hate thing.
Well maybe.
Yeah.
I think it's the same reason why some
people want to amputate their hands.
You know,
some people are just nuts.
That is kind of a nutty thing to do,
to want to catch,
you know,
like why I don't even want it now.
Even though I know that there's medicine
that stops it.
But we were talking about this yesterday
was like,
people that,
why do people like fisting?
It's just a show that your your past,
what everybody else is thinking of his
hardcore,
like I'll take a whole fist right up to
the elbow.
Some women's pussies are weird though,
man.
Like I gave the girl I dating a girl.
You used to never get all of it and I
would get.
I have little hands too,
but I'll get like the first four on my
part of my knuckle and that would be our
dirty talk.
Like she would go crazy when I would
talk to her and tell her that what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna I'm gonna.
I'm gonna curl the thumb.
When I told I was in a curl,
the thumbs she knew that the fist was
going in.
She'd go fucking nuts.
Even though I was just talking dirty
tour,
I would say I'm going to curl the thumb
and she knew that mental.
He's putting his fucking fight but I
couldn't.
It bitch.
Yeah.
I could never get all of it is I got.
I would get it in like this.
Like a,
like a praying mantis.
Like you're poking like a bird.
Yeah.
Well,
your thumb is touching the floor,
curled fates,
cheating.
It's a cheating way to fifth somebody.
I don't get it.
My asshole has zero ability to take more
than a finger.
Oh yeah,
a whole fist.
There's a video that Nick Swardson sent
me and Whitney were talking about it
yesterday.
We're,
there's a dude.
He's holding a dude up,
like in front of him,
like,
you know,
like a sort of a backpack on the front,
the guys around him and he's got his
fist all the way up to the elbow and
this guy's ass and he just keeps pumping
it up in there and he's holding the guy.
Yeah,
he's holding them up.
Oh,
he's got his arm wrapped around them and
then the other arm is just going in
their credit that both of those guys.
It's amazing.
Derek Pioneers for sure.
That reminds me of holding up.
I was watching season two again of the
ultimate fighter and there's one thing
where they do like how long,
how many rotations around the
heavyweight can.
I think they were either a middleweight
or welterweight.
Do were he climbs on top of the
heavyweight.
I've never seen that before.
Uh,
and he was going around like,
how many different times can you go
around this heavyweight body without
touching the ground?
I figured 10:50.
I mean it was fucking a hundred or 200
times the way around,
the ability to hold somebody else up.
But see,
the thing about something like that is
doing a contest like that.
You gotta realize that person's blown
their body out for days after that,
if that's not something you're
accustomed to and you're doing on a
daily basis,
that's like doing a chin up contest like
David Goggins,
like if you do that,
don't plan on fighting.
You know,
how is your arms are going to be blown
out,
your,
your legs are going to be blown out.
You're,
you're going to get fucked up.
It's definitely a good skill to have,
but doing something like that,
you could do it one time to find out
what your Max is,
but don't plan on recovering from that
anytime soon.
That's the thing about people in
injuries,
like one of the big problems with
injuries with MMA fighters,
Jujitsu people,
a lot of people is overtraining,
meaning you're not prepared for what
you're doing.
Like I have a friend,
my friend Cam hands runs a marathon a
day.
He runs a marathon every day.
Well,
he had a buildup to that.
Does he really?
Yeah.
He's.
He's training for this 238 Mile Moab a
race in October,
so if you're running 238 miles,
his ideas,
he gets a marathon in every day,
so his body is just constantly used to
this sort of stress,
but for him it's not that big a deal.
Like he'll run a marathon.
It's not a problem,
but if you tried to run a marathon every
day your body would break down.
You'd have some serious issues and the
first day I couldn't do it.
Yeah,
but again,
you might be able to do it.
It might be able to take you eight
hours.
You might be able to get through it,
but you're going to be fucked up for
awhile,
but if you built up to it slowly over
time you could develop the kind of
muscular endurance that allows you to do
something like that.
You get conditioned to it.
So like doing something like that where
you're doing like these rotations around
someone or you're doing like how many
times he climbed to the top of a 30 foot
rope,
you know,
someone's doing something like that.
If that's not something you do all the
time and you just try to do it once,
like on a television show for,
for funsies.
Sure.
You could fuck yourself up.
Yeah,
no,
I'm just saying things along those
lines.
Like when you're trying to do as many as
you can,
anytime you're doing as many as you can.
Like how many bodyweight squats can you
do?
Maybe 100,
you know,
like,
okay,
let's see if you can get to $500.
Good luck walking for the last couple of
days if that's.
If you try to do that.
I like a couple of.
Is it now this guy does chin up.
Does he do like the perfect military
ones?
Probably.
If he's a navy seal,
I'm sure you lil boys.
Full Body,
hand up.
Yeah.
Those kipping Chin ups are kind of where
they flop around like a fish are going
to use the ones where they go,
they lift up and then they go hire.
Like when they pull their full body
weight above the muscle up,
fuck that.
You're just chin up and then you do a
dip and then it's not.
It's a lot of people think it's not the
best functional exercise.
They think it looks cool and everything
like that,
but they don't believe it's.
It's a vest,
functional exercise,
but the guys that can do that,
so like I've always.
I've looked at guys do that with these
guys that do these,
these guys,
these guys are freaks.
These are outdoor guys where they work
outdoors and they can just do an endless
amount of things outdoors.
They can hold the bar sideways.
They're like,
look at what this guy's doing.
He's just doing like Chin ups and dips
and sideways.
Incredible.
The upper body strength and control.
Yeah.
Not just the strength but like the
static control,
these able to do like,
oh my God,
he's fuck.
It looks like he's being blown into a
hurricane.
Yeah,
a lot of people do those really called
flag poles.
Can you do that?
I've never done that.
Why am I saying that?
Surprising?
Of course I can't do it.
It's not easy,
but I could do it.
So what does,
what does that mean?
These guys don't have that kind of
balance.
Like that guy is a.
he's doing like a,
a dip to a handstand.
I can't do that in between the two bars.
Yeah.
And these guys,
they all wear,
which I find interesting.
I guess they do that because the,
the bars get sweaty.
Yeah.
You also don't want to slip and probably
flux your hands up.
Yeah.
I used to work little fingerless gloves
when I worked out just to keep my hands.
I'm like curly from mice and men like
dice.
Yeah,
exactly.
Keep my hand smooth and softwares those
because he are the one shake hands and I
was on.
I was on the road though.
He's the would do when someone would
come over,
he curls his.
He has a fingerless gloves.
They'll curl his fingers into the glove
and give them a fist to shake the
fucking worse.
He's so crazy.
He hated shaking hands with people and
he would go and watch this.
I remember one time we were out to eat
and some guy he washed his hands on.
Guy came over and shook his hand and
said,
oh,
I up.
I had to go to the bathroom again.
It's so funny that he's just,
he's such a pig on stage,
but he hates germs.
He likes fucking honey and his tea.
Like he's just a big Mama's boy.
He likes to be comforted.
He's an.
He's a very interesting guy.
Dies and he's also in a lot of ways a
pioneer because he was one of the very
first ever superstar stadium comedian.
Yes,
he was.
There was no one like that.
Like even kinison never hit that level
before.
Steve Martin,
I think at one point had that.
But yeah,
but.
And he had a tremendous mistake.
Tilt them to Steve Martin.
Was was,
was the biggest comic in the world for a
long time,
but dice had this thing where he,
uh,
he came out like a fist and just punch
through everything.
No one saw him coming.
There was no snl.
It was just this fucking animal.
Like,
I remember the first time I standardized
play.
I was a girl named Melanie who.
No,
no.
Uh,
uh,
whatever the fuck.
Her name is Michelle.
My girlfriend,
I was 18.
I was at her house.
So she's like,
come in here.
This guy is so dirty.
And I stood there and watched Andrew
dice clay the first time.
You remember Richard Price by favorite?
Carla.
I don't remember the first time I saw
them,
but I remember the first time I saw,
I remember the first time I played dice
dice cassette to this girl that I was
dating.
Her name was [inaudible].
She was from Nicaragua and uh,
we were in my car.
I think I was like,
I think I was 19 and uh,
we were sitting in my car playing this
dice clay thing,
fucking howling laughing.
I couldn't believe how dirty it was.
And how funny it was,
it was,
it was dirty and it was funny.
Do you,
do you ever have Florentine on?
No.
Oh yeah.
Have I had Jim on?
I feel like I have.
Jim Florentine is hilarious and when he
used to do is he would make his
girlfriend mixed tapes of all these
romantic songs and he would put fucking
bits from the day the laughter died and
the day of the laughter died and just
align or to play like a really nice song
that I want to eat.
You're cutting a big red chair.
And then I saw.
It's funny as a glass of milk my
favorite.
Heck align ever.
Yeah.
Oh.
Because dice had been talking about
drinking milk and slipping on it.
Like it's come.
People are slipping like somebody load
and the guy is so mad the audience,
he can't grasp what to say.
She goes,
you're a funny as a bottle of milk
because he just used what dice had just
said onstage.
Well,
we explained to people the day the
laughter died was when dice was on top
of the world.
He decided to record at danger fields
unannounced.
So danger
fields in New York is a historically
been like,
uh,
a poorly attended club.
Sure.
Like,
we would do shows how poorly attended it
is.
I did a show there once where I think my
spot was probably like at 9:00
and I got there at 8:30
and uh,
there's just a couple of comics hanging
out at the bar.
I was like,
what's going on?
And they go,
no one's here yet.
And I go,
what?
No one's here.
There's no audience.
So two people showed up a couple.
They said a,
we're here to show.
And Remember Scotty,
the big guy,
the big Irish guy,
bobby,
bobby rather.
Oh yeah,
bottom.
He was Scott.
I'm sorry I fucked it up.
Bobby.
He was like,
right this way,
ladies and gentlemen.
And he brought these people into an
empty room and they're like,
what?
And they sat them down and then the MC
went up.
So they started to show a half hour late
because that was the first time people
showed up and we all did sets for two
fucking people have done.
It was really weird.
So dice sides to record his album.
They're unannounced with no material.
He had no preparation.
He just winged it the entire thing and
it's both brilliant and terrible at the
same time.
It's a two CD thing because it was like
he was up there for fucking hours,
three nights,
and he was up there with.
That's dice at danger fields from the
special that that's when he did Rodney
dangerfield special.
So we toured with him.
No,
that he was on Rodney Dangerfield,
HBO special.
That's how he broke.
And then he came back and did the day.
The laughter died.
But I don't think there's any pictures.
Clips out of Kenny was with him when he
did those.
Those cds.
I'm so jealous that he got to watch
those tapings.
Well Kenny was like his bodyguard or
something,
right.
Wasn't manager body guard.
When I first started the dice it was
like 1997 and it was.
Kenny was the road manager and a body
guard.
Is that Rodney and Fabio?
Wow.
Is that and dice?
Who's that?
Rodney.
His wife would get mad,
I guess.
Is that Rodney's wife or no?
Is that Fabio getting married?
Someone's getting married.
Fabio can get married with a shirt open
like that radius.
So that day the laughter died for
Comedians.
There was a guy named Mike Donovan who's
a Boston comedy legend.
Fucking hilarious,
hilarious comedian,
and he is the one who told me about the
day the laughter died,
didn't he?
We were in the back of the comedy
connection and he was just laughing
until he was crying,
talking about dice,
do an impression of Nixon while he's
eating.
I'll do Nixon in that ass.
Give me that book.
Fat fucking.
I mean,
he was doing a Nixon impression while
he's eating as and for whatever reason,
Mike Donovan thought it was the funniest
thing I've ever heard in his life.
He's just cry and laugh and it's like,
this is a brilliant,
brilliant album.
It is Rick Rubin producers out there.
Yeah.
For that album.
It's a.
it's an odd masterpiece.
it's,
it's a beautiful that he did that
because there is a flow to it,
but it's like it's the greatest.
Watching a comics mind just fucking
randomly bounce from joke to joke to
bomb to joke and just really exploring
and grabbing for shit.
Yeah.
And there's no material preparation,
you know,
you can tell he's just totally ad
libbing.
Yeah.
That's the album cover.
I remember getting it and listening to
and being so close.
Look at that cassette one.
Yeah.
And people who didn't know I liked,
there was also people who didn't like
it,
like this sucks.
What is this?
But uh,
Chris rock is at the seller one night
and I forget how it goes,
the best comedy album ever.
One of them he said did after that I'll
have to die by Angela,
but that's also the best comedy album
for him because he's a comic and he
thinks it's hilarious.
This guy just went up there and just had
no fucking no preparation whatsoever.
I've laughed harder.
But your prior albums,
and I did it that there are better
comedy record,
but as far as being a pure thing to show
like what comics do sometimes to work
stuff out.
He literally,
like you said,
Papa,
this game,
he was fucking 19,
99.
Probably sold a million copies of that
too.
Yeah,
to a fucking 800,000
unhappy people.
He didn't even call the day the laughter
die.
He didn't give a fuck.
He would go up sometimes and literally
like to see how long he could go without
getting a laugh and clubs.
He would just fuck around and see how
long he could go and not get a laugh.
My favorite is insult.
Dice.
When you find someone in the audience
and go look,
good,
you look good to really cut your fucking
hair digging on people and they wouldn't
know whether to laugh or be upset and it
would be like.
It was almost angry at them for being
alive.
He described women's tits and he and he
goes,
look at those big fat fucking mother
fucking fat fucking tits.
And it was really dirty,
but I'm like,
my God,
that's emotionally the best description
of tits.
Everyone's big ones.
That's how you feel though.
You can't get the words that will
describe the lust of big breasts,
more than fat.
Fucking motherfucking fat.
Fucking it.
There was something so guttural about
that.
I'm like,
that's the greatest description of tits.
And nobody's ever given.
As far as emotionally for a guy.
Well,
you know what dice did to that nobody
else has ever done before or since.
Has He created punchlines that everybody
wanted to repeat?
Yes.
Those wines are amazing.
People wanting to repeat what's in the
bowl bitch.
Like he would point the microphone to
the audience and they knew the punchline
and they would yell it out and cheer.
Yeah,
on day left die.
They tried doing a poem.
He goes,
no stupid.
Like doing poems.
Know poems.
Yeah.
He had no qualms.
Not even,
hey,
I'm not doing that.
Like Robin Williams did in the album
called a reality.
What a concept,
which was the first dirty album I ever
had was Robin Williams reality.
What a cop before even prior and he and
somebody yelled out,
mark and Robin goes,
I'm not doing more.
Come here to do something different.
Like he,
he did it nicely and people clapped,
but he didn't go.
No,
like with dice,
they needed them that night and they're
just trying to connect with other poem
and he could've got them.
Fuck you.
They get it.
They almost were being punked like they
were there for a comedy show and the
most famous comic alive at the time.
Yes.
Came up and just ate dick for three
hours a day for three fucking hours over
three night period.
It's a nine hour fucking ball munching,
but he also,
it was funny male,
he dies.
Changed the language.
Like people like what did political
correct to start.
If you look back to when it really
kicked in,
it was.
They were so disgusted and angry at
dice.
That was what kicked political.
Correct.
Plus,
you know,
the Internet was really kicking in.
There's a lot of factors,
but dice is the one who was,
he was the straw that broke the broke
people like I can't fucking take
anymore.
We have to stop talking this way.
Well,
he went on MTV,
remember the,
he did a bunch of jokes that they didn't
approve and they banned him from MTV for
life.
And meanwhile,
today that's a God damn.
I mean,
badge of honor.
Yeah,
he went,
nobody wants to be on MTV now,
but back then it was like,
Holy Shit.
They banned him from Auntie VI.
Kennison criticized him for that.
He built,
he went out and Kurt loder was on TV
talking about how unfunny terrible
unfunny period jokes,
you know,
it's like,
but it was this,
this air of like pompousness like,
and he was talking about this is
progressive,
you know,
Kurt loder type character who was always
like the guy who told you about the
amazing,
cool new bands was telling you the dice,
just terrible and unfunny and you'll
never be on MTV.
Uh,
Ken and I remember thinking that like,
whoa.
They banned him from siren it live.
They banned him from MTV.
He didn't give a fuck or Kenny again.
I,
Kenny told me that the Guy Andrew may
have told me this too,
but before he went out,
he was thinking of doing it.
It might've been,
I'm not.
Who's The guy?
Johnny?
Uh,
Johnny he had with them,
um,
whose name I don't remember fucking.
Oh my God.
You know,
it's the journey that he traveled with
for years.
Is it possible to not noodles?
Um,
no,
something johnny.
But he said,
uh,
he said to dice,
do you want to be a teardrop or a tidal
wave?
Which I thought was such a great fucking
piece of advice to give someone before
he went out on live television with that
dilemma.
Well now I mean,
now that it's all the dust has been
settled.
Who?
Johnny what?
What's the,
what was his name?
No hot tubs.
John and Jesus.
I never met him.
I'd never met him.
He was he a comic?
I don't know.
He was dices guy.
He write wrote with dice.
He toured with them.
I think he was the road manager at one
point,
but I never met hot tub.
It was.
Kenny was there when I came in in 1997,
but that was the name fucking forgetting
shit man.
You went well.
It's just like a slick rick should
happen.
Yeah,
it does.
Well,
you have too many experiences,
you know,
like you talked to someone who lives in
a small town about a small town
and the stuff that he does in that town
that motherfucking can remember
everything,
but talk to a guy who travels the world
and to stand up and takes pills to stop
getting aids.
Boy,
what a sigh of relief.
I was fucking,
I'll tell you,
one of the most nervous I've ever been
was when I took the,
uh,
just to digress for a second,
was to take the uh,
I was so convinced that HIV and I
fucking took this oral test that you can
get from cvs.
And there's a weird thing where you just
said it's up a good up until the last
three months.
It's like in the high,
90 percent accurate.
Not One hundred percent,
but it's a good precursor to the bucket
blood.
So I did it.
And you have to,
you,
you rub it on your gums once each and
then you put it in this,
this,
uh,
this folding,
like almost like a trapper keeper.
And you close it and they say what
happens is there's a red line and if
there's two red lines,
you're positive,
the one red line stays there.
And they said,
do not watch the progress because it
will freak you out.
Don't watch it.
Of course you watch it only for a second
because I literally thought I saw the
beginning of a second line and I
remember closing it and I'm like,
I have HIV.
I was fucking convinced.
I went,
I remember where I went.
It went down to the fucking store,
bought a couple of rx bars.
I'm like,
I'm just going to have a nice fucking
protein bar and go back and 20 minutes,
whatever it was.
And I couldn't black I to photograph it.
I couldn't believe that I was negative.
But I came back and it was clear I was,
I was a hundred percent convinced that
HIV was scary.
Man.
I'm well anytime there's something like
that where you don't know if you have it
and if you do have it,
it's a death sentence or even it wasn't
even that thought was die because now
there's so many.
This is recent,
this is probably three months ago.
There's so many medications you can
take,
but it's the idea of having to tell a
partner and like,
who's going to want to fuck you with
that?
Like that's just a rough one.
You know what I mean?
I'm dating someone.
I'm going to tell her I kind of Charlie
Sheen,
get it.
I don't know.
And if you noticed that was the question
that Matt Lauer,
I don't believe asked.
Um,
I don't think they got into it.
So I don't know.
Yeah.
So Matt Lauer and him talk because he
was getting blackmailed.
Yes,
he was.
There's a shit ton of lawsuits because
he had an unprotected sex without
telling a bunch of people that he had
it.
That's crazy.
I mean,
that's,
that's crazy.
Even if you're down to zero,
then you still got to tell them,
tell them to zero where it's not visible
because they can knock it down to where
it's undetectable and I really do think
you can't pass it then because there are
drugs that you won't be able to pass it
and prep.
We won't able to get it,
but I still think you're obligated to
say it.
You know,
you're obligated to say it and then you
let that person make the decision.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You,
you,
you can't make that decision for them.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
But I mean this is all cocaine party
mean everyone's just having terrible
judgment.
Yeah.
I imagine that was quite a bit of
naughty behavior in the residence times
doing tremendous amounts of blow.
Yeah.
Like they would talk about him doing
below that would kill a normal size
person.
I heard somebody to what I've heard
about the black male and I don't know,
I really wish I knew who had blacked
out.
I don't.
Was that got a picture of
medication in his medicine cabinet is a
video of him sucking a guy's Dick.
Um,
I've heard that too.
I've heard that,
but I don't know.
That's true.
I mean,
you think he probably didn't know that
video's being to y'all that was taken
without him knowing.
Well,
who knows?
Maybe when you're coked up like film it.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean when you have a kid that's rough.
I mean otherwise,
like who cares if he sucked a dick who
gives a fuck?
And you're great and platoon when you
give a shit.
But you know what I mean?
It gives a fuck.
Major League who's really,
you know,
believe me,
I'm very unsung.
Film it.
Wall Street.
It was good in it.
Ha.
Very good.
Most him and Martin Sheen together.
Fuck crazy.
I think that a certain point in time
when you're doing that kind of drugs,
like you're doing crazy disassociative
piles of blow and you're fucking,
you don't know where the fuck you are.
You're freaking out.
You're constantly paranoid.
They said its teeth were rotting out of
his head.
It looked like a few pictures of his
teeth did not look like they are in
amazing shape.
A sheen also doesn't know how he
contracted the virus,
but told lauer it had nothing to do with
needles.
Oh,
well then he does have a good idea.
Well,
how could he say?
it means you mean sexually.
He had nothing.
He never did anything with needles.
Rumors about the actress health recently
emerged in the tabloid press.
So where,
where,
where's he at now?
Like he's like Khan.
He's kind of fucking radio dark,
nothing.
He just did a film.
He did a film that nine slash 11,
but people trapped in an elevator.
He's um,
and they said,
well,
you know,
he had some conspiracy theories they
shouldn't have cast.
So it gives a fuck.
It's a movie.
None of these people are dead.
They're alive.
They just did a movie.
Well,
do you remember he wrote an open letter
to President Obama.
He's a big fan of Alex Jones and friend
of Alex Jones.
And He,
Alex Jones called me up.
Hey Man,
Gary Busey wants to talk to you.
And then he fucking.
Gary Busey.
And Gary Busey talked to me and he's
like,
uh,
I mean Carrie pcs completely out of his
fucking lie.
But Gary Busey as an excuse.
Gary Busey got in a motorcycle accident
with no helmet and caved his head in
like real bad.
That's why Gary Busey,
when you're looking at one eyes up here,
he's got that Shannon Shannon Doherty
thing going on.
Oh,
it's down here when I was up there.
It's because it's literal skull was
destroyed in a motorcycle accident.
He hit a fucking curb with his hedge,
right?
Yeah.
And seeing that picture,
if his eyebrows are up,
it makes it look like he's okay.
But I'm getting to the one on our right.
His left is the one that drew.
That's what it looks like is left as
Jack.
But he,
we've had him in a couple of times when
he came back in,
he remembered my.
I thought like,
he's loopy,
but he's not like,
out of it.
Like,
yeah,
he knew.
I mean he wasn't.
He's a little nutty,
but he's always been a little nutty.
But he didn't know.
He remembers lying.
He can,
he can act.
Yeah.
See how his right eyebrows up?
Right.
Eyes up and left.
One's down.
Yeah.
He had a significant brain injury.
There it is.
Oh yeah.
Before that,
before that accident,
he was a pretty normal guy.
He has that injury.
That's fucking TB.
They already called Tbi.
Traumatic brain.
That fucking wide open.
Look at you again.
Will you see guys are both eyes like
that?
They're fucking cooked.
Well,
there's a little bit of that,
but I believe there's structural damage
to his actual skull itself.
I think I'm.
I'm.
I'm almost positive that he hit the curb
without a helmet is when la didn't have
helmet laws and he wiped out and curbed
is fucking brain and was lucky to be
alive,
if I remember correctly.
Yeah.
I don't remember when that was,
but.
Oh fuck motorcycles,
man.
They scare me.
They,
I watched all this website I go to.
I watch a lot of terrible things that I
shouldn't watch,
but I fucking seen these motorcycle
accidents.
I'll always watch and car accidents
because that really does remind me to
drive safe.
Like you can't control everything,
but when I say guy burning to death in a
car or fucking cut in half,
I'm like,
maybe it's not his fault.
Oh yeah.
He went under a tractor trailer.
He was texting and driving and that's
what it looks like.
Don't fucking do it.
So I'm really,
really cautious when I drive I by Les.
We drove in your Porsche.
Last one we did if I can pay and I was
like,
wow,
you're a responsible porsche driver.
Like you don't drive like an animal at
all.
No.
All you have pretty much around the
limit.
Maybe a little over.
But you weren't a fucking maniac?
No,
I don't drive fast.
I would never drive fast with a friend
of the car either.
I don't.
I'm not a dickhead driver.
Occasionally I've dickhead moments for
when no one's around,
but I don't.
I don't put anybody else in danger.
I don't.
I don't believe in driving like that.
No.
It was a delightful Dr.
it was not frightening at all.
It was comfortable with it.
You get nervous when you got into the
car.
I didn't know I've driven with you
before,
but if I didn't know you I might,
but just having a porsche,
it's just known as somebody who's going
to move that car in particular because
it's so loud and so bouncy and you know,
but I think you do a lot more to lose
than I do.
So I'm like,
I figured you'd be driving safe.
Like I'm like,
it's not like you don't want to drive
with the guy who has nothing.
Like how you doing?
Oh I just lost my fucking house.
I ain't got no gig and these two red
lines getting the cat.
I just put a new engine and so yeah,
you want to go with a guy who's got a
little bit more to lose than you do.
But it was safe.
Comfortable.
Right.
Like those cars because they're light
and the responsive and so it's like
riding a ride,
like a Disneyland ride everywhere you
go.
It doesn't,
I don't like,
I don't want people.
How fast have you ever gotten it to?
I've never gotten it that fast.
I don't drive that fast.
I don't,
I'm not.
I like cornering,
like I'm into cars that grip and feel
good.
When you're,
you're,
you're connected to the machine.
BMW.
Drive like that.
Dumping.
Sure.
Yeah.
I had one.
This wheel is a kind of stiff and they
said that that's for.
It's because high performance encrypts
the road.
Well,
they have a bunch of different settings
you could put on a bmw,
especially the m cars.
They can make the,
you can vary the stiffnesses of the uh,
steering because they're a electronic
power assist.
But uh,
the,
if you want a car that lists are really
responsive.
That's a BMW.
They have an m two.
It's a tiny little car.
It's like one of their least,
least expensive m cars,
but most enthusiastic it's their best
one.
I don't,
I've driven.
I had,
you know,
had the XX.
I drove like three in a row.
I was leasing them.
They were really big cars and I was
like,
I want,
I kind of wanted a Mercedes or a lot
cheaper.
I've never driven over selling fucking
Mercedes with cheaper.
This was a much cheaper,
much cheaper.
The BMW is just too big.
I live in the city,
I have a car because I like to drive.
It's like for what?
My addiction.
If I said I kept that because years ago
I would ride around and look at fucking
hookers.
That was.
Yes,
that was why I did,
but I might've been.
I might've been doing that now.
Like I'm totally out of that.
The actual cruising,
the pay pay and people.
Yeah.
I know.
I pay pal for dirty videos sometimes in
movies of girls who are doing things
just because you know what I mean,
but just paying for sex.
The sex trafficking shit just freaked me
out too much.
Oh,
that's awful.
It freaked me out too much and I know
I'm all for consensual,
like women,
like I,
I talked to a woman once who was a.
she's,
I guess you could say she was an escort.
She had,
she had done porn and she stopped doing
porn and she said the way she said it,
she likes,
she said she had clients and I was like,
well how does that work?
And she's like,
well off the record there's a bunch of
guys that I've had sex with in the past
and I liked them and they pay me and
I'll go over there and it's almost like
people I really like and I have sex with
them and I said like,
how many times a week?
She goes,
I only need to do it a few times a week
and I pay my bills,
you know,
girls like that.
After I stopped going on certain sites,
girls like that who I knew it was
important me,
like I knew their lives,
who they were under their real names.
I knew their facebook,
like you know what a person's life is
and they're just choosing to do this on
the side because a,
you have a chemistry with them and they
like you and be they.
Some of them are just dirty.
I've met plenty of just dirty and enjoy
it.
Well,
I didn't know her too well and I didn't
ask too many questions,
but from what she was saying,
it was essentially like,
you know,
she had done porn,
she didn't want to do porn anymore and
she didn't want to be just a quote
unquote hooker,
but she had a few guys that wanted to
have sex and would be willing to pay her
and I guess they apparently a couple
thousand bucks and she would just have
sex with these guys a couple times a
week,
different guys and she'd make four or
$5,000
a week and she wouldn't have to worry
about shit and she could do whatever she
wanted to do for as long as my body
holds up.
I mean when I talked to this quite a
long time ago,
I think she was probably like 36 or 37
at the time,
so it's like maybe she can't do that
anymore.
Maybe now she's 46,
47 or 50 and maybe dudes will.
How much they try to find an older sugar
daddy,
I think,
or a guy that they've stayed.
That's where they start.
That's probably when they want to wife
up to like when you're.
Yeah.
That's a hard thing for men.
Like a lot of men do not want to shack
up with a chick that had sex for money.
You know,
I don't mind it.
Like I don't want them doing it when I'm
with them,
but I like somebody with the past.
I really need it because my past is so
fucked up.
I much prefer yours as to what the fuck
is this Jamie?
The Korean grandmothers or sell sex?
How do you pull these up so quick?
What do you have on tab?
Like what is wrong with you?
I saw this story the other day.
I don't remember as a video about the
box.
It's called Baucus ladies,
I believe it's a drink called Baka.
So they walk around selling the baucus
as an energy
drink to a step.
Like there were like 40 and 50 year old
women,
but now they're elderly women are doing
it too and so you buy the drink but
you're buying sex is what you're
reading.
What it says.
I don't understand the way around the
loophole.
A loophole,
prostituted,
you buy this drink and I'll give you sex
or like street vendors with energy
drinks,
but when you buy it from them,
you're really saying,
hey,
come with me somewhere.
I guess where is this happening on
Korea?
South Korea.
Pretty smart work around.
So the guys by the energy drink knowing
that they're gonna get some sex.
That's what the video described.
Yeah,
technically is a,
but I just,
I've known too many people I've known
who were like pseudo forced into it by a
boyfriend and one girl I was talking to
recently was the industry like yeah,
my boyfriend had made me kind of do it
and she got wanted to at one point,
but then he hit me when I didn't want.
I'm asleep man.
There's too many people.
I don't know their story.
If I can guarantee there's just
consensual,
I'm fine with it being legal,
I don't care.
But it freaked me out that there was too
many people that I didn't know enough
about.
Like I never go to places.
I never went to those places because
they felt too much like the Russian mob
or the Asian,
whatever it was controlling them,
but then even people I thought I knew,
I'm like,
I can't guarantee it and I can't.
Well that's very ethical of you.
Like you were thinking about them being
forced into that life over time.
It just got to me because more like I
would talk to different people and at
first it was like,
Eh,
the feminist.
Of course they're going to say that,
but then there was certain people that
said certain things that someone just
says something.
See there's some feminists that think
it's empowering for a woman to be able
to choose what to do with her body.
I know,
I know a woman who's a very smart woman
and when she was younger she had done
and she's an artist.
She had done some sex work but it was
just like she fucked some guys for money
and like for her it was like easier than
working.
Yeah.
And I'm not saying I think it should be
legalized.
I think that people should be able to do
that.
I just personally,
as I was getting older and I'm like,
this is not what I want to do anymore.
I think boring.
Well it's also,
you know,
it just anytime someone's being forced
to do something and then there's
potential shame attached to it.
Like I don't think there's anything
wrong with sex and I don't know.
You don't either,
but when you attach the potential
societal shame aspect of it,
like your behavior,
your choices could shame you can be a
real problem.
You know,
like the same thing with sex,
right?
Like people having sex.
Who Care?
Everybody have sex.
We'd love sex people.
Most people love sex,
right?
But the idea of you being caught on film
having sex is terrifying for a lot of
people,
which is really weird.
It's really weird.
Like we know you love sex,
but if we see you having sex,
well,
shame.
Yeah,
it's a really.
You're right,
because it's almost like this why I hate
when people break into these hard drives
in the cloud for these celebrities
because it's a weird privacy thing.
Like even if you're not doing something
you're not supposed to have.
You talked to your wife,
you talked to your girlfriend,
who wants people hearing that it's
embarrassing and it's private.
I'm,
look,
I'm very open about most things sexually
in my life,
but I still don't want people to read
specific things I've said because it
just feels like invasion of privacy
page and it's also like you didn't write
it for other people to hear and there's.
There's things you say to your friends,
right,
that if they took out of context,
people would go,
well Jim Norton's a fucking asshole.
He's a piece of shit.
Like,
like even in just like this thing that I
did with Ari sent him a text message
that I put it on instagram is Avi.
I thought it pretty obvious that it was
in jest,
but so many people thought it was really
like the context of your friendship and
people who don't understand they don't
know you.
And then there's also the comedian
factor.
Like the way we talk to each other on a
regular basis is so different than the
way a lot of folks can because if you're
working in an office job nine to five
every day you're controlled by human
resources and the the,
the,
the office standards of behavior.
You have to follow some sort of a firing
guidelines of what's term to what you
can get terminated for those people are
on the edge and tiptoeing on fucking
broken glass every day.
It's scary and you know is Sirius Xm is
a corporate environment and I'm fucking.
I'm a fucking dirty comic and I'm more
careful around the women there than half
of the fucking newscasters.
You hear about getting.
It's like if I know that as a fucking
dirt bag,
you don't fucking hit on the women at
work.
Ask them gently,
did we talk about now okay and fuck off.
Well not even worse,
but these guys weren't just doing that.
They were sexually harassed.
Absolutely.
It's crazy.
It's not that they were hitting on him.
I mean,
office environments are just Whitney.
Cummings is a very funny joke about
that.
I don't want to say it because it's,
it's one of her new bits about working
in an office,
but there's so much sexual tension when
you're stuck in a room with people for
eight hours a day and if two people are
attracted to each other and they're
working side by side on a daily basis,
occasionally they test the waters and
say fucked up things and then saying
those fucked up things.
Women are allowed to do whatever they
want essentially.
Like it's really hard.
It's really hard for her to get fired.
Yeah.
I mean a woman says something dirty you.
It's kind of funny,
but if a guy says something unwanted and
dirty,
it's really disgusting because why?
Well,
because men rape in,
they're more dangerous and they're
scarier.
You know,
they're physically more scary.
So a guy intruding on a woman's space
and saying creepy,
unwanted sexual shit has an air of
danger to it.
Whereas if a girl is saying some creepy,
unwanted sexual shit to me,
I can go,
hey,
stop.
You know,
like you can't say don't talk to them.
Like precursor to her making you do it.
Yeah.
It's never,
she's going to grab my head,
forced me to eat her pussy.
Yeah.
Great thought though,
isn't being made to do it.
That's one of my greatest being made to
be made.
Stick your tongue up further.
Sniff it.
Fart in your mouth.
Yeah,
we've all been there.
You ever have someone do that?
I'd have it.
It was all right.
Not Bad.
Not that.
No.
I had a girl and I didn't go.
And did I tell you this?
She's trying to push a fart out and she
shot monistat seven on my chest.
Oh,
it was fucking monistat seven is
something girls putting their vagina
infection.
Oh,
Jesus is not my best moment.
Would it smell like?
I don't believe it had a smell.
I don't remember having a smell.
You had to explain that it was Monistat
so exactly what it was.
We both knew what it was.
You know?
It was a bad.
It was a bad scene,
but she was really fucking sexy.
Big Fat ass.
Yeah.
Just trying to Fart on you.
Yeah,
just take.
I mean,
I don't really care about that,
but I was like,
yeah,
why not?
Quite my face.
That's whose idea was it?
Mine,
but I think she said I have to.
I'm like,
go ahead.
What are you already said you have to
you?
She said,
no,
I think she said I have to Fart.
Oh,
she said I have to Fart.
Fart in my mouth.
Yeah.
We had always done that.
Besides did licked her ass and she's
great at.
You know what I mean?
We were kind of far from that.
Nah,
not that I know of.
Somebody must have terrible way to feel
like,
why didn't I just shower up first?
I don't like to shower them up first.
I don't like the.
I like this.
I like a scent.
I literally like.
You liked that you liked sheep?
I liked them.
I was telling you like,
I'll tell her like if I'm dating you and
I like you,
I literally have thrown girlfriends,
deodorants out.
Really?
I fucking do.
You want them to stink a little?
Yes,
but I have to fucking way you're saying
it,
but I have to like them.
Oh,
it has to be.
It's a chemistry thing.
That's nature telling you who you should
fucking who you shouldn't fuck,
because some people sent repulses me the
smell of their mouth or the smell of
their skin repulses me,
unhealthy people probably.
Or even people that I'm just not meant
to breed with.
But then there's some people,
the underarm smell the smell of their
feet when they're stinky.
Dude,
it makes me not dirty.
I don't like dirty feet.
Like I don't want you to talk a little
stinky in socks and sneakers because
clean.
There's a whole fucking thing of it
here.
So orderly,
but clean.
It is intense.
Your eyes,
you're like,
no,
no socks and sneakers because it's clean
because you do feel like a creep when
you're talking to a girl and you say to
her like,
I want your feet to be a certain way I
would say,
but you want to let her know,
don't make them dirty.
Like don't come over and flip flops or I
don't want you walking around on a,
on a,
on a floor without.
You know what I mean?
Like I like,
I'm a hygiene person.
Sweaty.
Yeah.
But um,
I've been with that with girls.
I tell them like,
don't shower for three days.
Oh,
Jesus makes me crazy.
And what do they say?
Great.
Really the good ones,
this is great.
Honestly,
they fucking love it.
Um,
but again,
if I don't like you,
if I'm not attracted to your San,
I have no desire for that.
So that's how I know I meant to be with
somebody.
You know,
Chris Ryan,
Dr Chris Ryan,
who was a friend of mine was telling me
that women,
when they're on birth control pills,
their ability to smell whether or not a
mate is sexually compatible with them
gets hindered by the birth control pill.
It fucks it up.
But when they have women that are not on
birth control pills,
they can literally smell a man's clothes
and find out whether or not they're
sexually compatible with them.
Just whether or not they're attracted to
them.
Like there's a literally a specific
scent and that sent
they think is not just like whether or
not you're sexually attracted to someone
smell,
but whether or not you're biologically
compatible with them.
Like do you remember back in the day
when people would get married,
they would do blood tests to see if they
could have kids remember that?
I don't.
There was a thing that they used to talk
about,
like people would have tests to see it.
I don't know if,
you know,
it was legitimately scientifically
valid,
but they would have tests like a blood
test and I remember people talking about
this when I was in high school like that
married people would have go and have
these blood tests to see if they could
not,
not pregnancy.
Oh No,
no,
not pregnancy,
but whether or not they were compatible.
Like as far as like raising healthy
kids.
There was some weird.
I mean it might've been some bullshit
fake science that they tried to pass off
back in the seventies and the eighties,
but I distinctly remember people
talking.
This is like before I was anywhere near
blood typing compatibility.
Yeah.
Blood types of categorized by a,
B and o.
we're reading something here and given
the rh factor of positive or negative,
Abo and rh in compatibility happens when
a mother's blood type conflicts with
that of a newborn child.
It's possible for the mothers red blood
cells to cross into the placenta or
fetus during pregnancy.
Yeah,
but that's.
I'm incompatibilities between a mother
and a child.
I think it's between a man and a woman
and the way they have theirs is probably
bullshit,
but it was something that people used to
do a lot.
I remember people talking about it.
I remember people talking about it when
I had a very,
very limited understanding of biology,
so I was probably in high school and
even before that,
but I was like,
what blood tests?
They have to take a blood test.
I'm like,
what if you love somebody and you want
to get married to them?
You find out that you take a blood test
and it doesn't work out.
Like how does that work?
Maybe the worker,
maybe that's such a nature thing.
Like maybe if it's not meant to be,
it can still work.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Nature may work on this fucking base
level.
Well yeah,
it's still going to work,
but that's like letting you know,
it will work.
Like,
do you know what I mean?
It may still work fine if you're sent is
off,
but they're closed.
Thing makes sense.
There was a girl I had come over.
She would come over and mood fuck around
and she wouldn't.
Her underarms with smell and it made me
fucking bonkers,
man.
I was so attracted to her since she left
a jacket in my house,
the fucking armpit.
I smelled the armpits for six months.
You're so fucked up.
It's dude.
I fucking sniffed the armpit and I'm not
a guy who's into toys or clothing.
Like as far as a woman,
I don't usually want their panties.
I'm the girl I'm seeing now.
I do though.
I do want to.
We're trying to figure out a way for her
to fedex overnight and your panties.
I've never asked to go do that my life
ever tell her to put them in a Ziploc.
Of course,
of course,
of course.
That was number.
Want me to tell him to tape the zip lock
so it doesn't open up?
Yes,
but I mean that's really ultra rare that
I actually want that.
But this girl's jacket hung in my closet
and I fucking smelled.
That drove me crazy for months.
I'm having Deja Vu.
Losing today's
parents says that you should be getting
blood tests for screening because
they can find out if they're going to
have potential blood diseases and stuff.
Yeah.
But that's.
Today's parent is at a website.
Yeah.
Who's that knows?
Is that a common practice?
That's what I mean.
It says,
uh,
this was like an article that says test
you need to be getting before pregnancy
and there's like a pre pregnancy checkup
for the man and the woman,
right.
Prenatal vaccinations and then sexually
transmitted diseases,
you need to check for it to end genetic
screening.
It says so they just do like probably
overall blood tests.
It's very interesting.
[inaudible] you don't hear about that
anymore.
It's not like,
you know,
I,
you don't hear about that from doctors.
You don't hear about that when people
were trying to get pregnant.
You don't hear about that from
newlyweds.
Just don't hear about it.
The blood tests.
Yeah,
like getting blood tests to make sure
that your kids would be healthy or I
wonder now though if there's so much
stress put on disease shit like aids the
day we still say get a blood test and
get tested and all this stuff is
handled,
but maybe we just don't talk about the
other aspect of it because the big one
is HIV or whatever or hey,
like,
you know,
get you had to check to see what
diseases you're family has.
Like maybe we're still talking about it,
but it's just not being phrased the same
way.
This is why I don't think it's true
because we went to a very good doctor
and you know,
I have,
I have kids.
I never took a fucking test.
The shot loads in there and made kids.
He just alluded to it.
I mean I just don't.
I don't know.
I mean maybe I dunno.
I Dunno.
I Dunno about the science of all that
stuff and I just don't know why it was
never discussed,
but I do remember being a kid where that
was a big deal like that a parent,
these two parents would get a blood test
before they got married and make sure
they could have kids and it just never
hear about that shit anymore.
Yeah.
I don't even remember hearing about it
back then to be honest,
but it does make sense.
Like,
Hey,
let's just see if there's going to be
like if there's an obvious problem that
will show up through the blood test.
Well how fucking weird is it that you
could have a different kind of blood in
me?
Like your blood might be a in mind.
Might be,
oh,
like your blood is in my body.
I'm fucked.
Yeah.
I got to keep my body.
It's not even compatible.
So that's what's so strange.
It's like we vary so much biologically
that we have different kinds of blood
and one is not good in the other.
Yeah,
I mean there's some bloods that are
universal.
I believe it's o positive is a universal
blood donor and anyone can take it.
Yeah,
that's what I have.
I believe that my blood can go into
other people's body and it's okay to
find out if that's true.
I don't know what I am.
I probably should know.
Yeah,
he's probably 50.
Jesus.
I know.
I'm busy.
I'm fucking.
I didn't ever check that busy.
Just getting panty sent to me.
I know,
I know.
I'm not really big on the undergarments
though.
I mean,
um,
you know,
a couple girls have had them.
I thought there were sexy.
What is it about women wearing those
stockings with the straps that go up to
the underwear so hot because you're
seeing something you're not supposed to
be.
Real Universal.
Red Cell donor has type O negative o o
negative.
I think I'm o positive.
Universal plasma donor has ab blood type
R,
H in general.
Rh negative blood is giving to rh
negative patients and rh blood or
rh negative blood may be giving to rh
positive patients.
Universal red cell donor has type O,
o o negative blood type.
Mm.
Um,
I need to figure out what I'm talking
about.
Yeah.
I don't know much about the blood stuff
at all.
I mean for me it's just a,
you know,
what drives me sexually,
like I know what I,
you know,
like let's,
it is weird how some people can be like
really pretty,
but you don't find them attractive at
all.
And then other people not nearly as
pretty,
but you think they're so sexy.
I've dated people who will this trigger
words that we all like,
so a good trigger word,
poof,
that goes a long way.
Like it's not the dirty porn words,
you know what I mean?
You like that shit shut up now for me
it's not,
it's not a series of words or that kind
of shit.
I'm not get not as dirty as you,
but uh,
for me it's just a personality thing
that someone is comfortable,
like someone is comfortable in their own
skin and fun to be around and,
and,
and I'm passionate,
you know,
but also like affectionate,
like affectionate to me is very sexy.
So you have different things.
We all have those things.
I actually,
yours is better because to me that's a
more normal thing to be and then just a
healthier thing without needing bells
and whistles and fucking juggling and,
and you know,
and to see a woman with perfect features
and she's cold and she's not friendly
and nice.
I don't find her attractive at all.
Yeah.
It does nothing for you to a woman who's
like way less,
like classically attractive,
but she's very affectionate and very
kind and sweet and fun to be around.
I find that very attractive.
That will vary from person to person.
I can go with kind and sweet or I can go
with this certain words I like when they
say like,
some people just get it and they know
how to talk and they know,
they know your fucking triggers and it's
just,
it's an ownership for you.
For me.
Yeah.
You got weird kinks.
Yeah man.
It's all the night is crazy with this.
Again,
the personality,
not crazy.
I just like her or I love her.
Whatever the fuck.
What is it though?
What do you do?
Have you ever tried to examine like what
are kinks?
Like where is it coming from?
Like what,
what is it about like trigger words and
weird things and weird stuff that like
gets you turned on like w and w,
is it how you're interfacing with the
world?
Is it how you're choosing to address all
of your issues and that you can escape
them with like really like crazy
behavior and that like maybe you have
all these anxieties and neurosis and
that through this really bizarre dirty
talk and freaky behavior.
You can escape those because it's so
naughty.
It's so off the [inaudible] you're not a
normal guy.
Right?
But none of us are.
If we're working in show business.
If you're a standup comedian,
right?
You're getting paid to talk crazy shit
on stage or you're not normal.
You're,
your world is in normal.
You wake up whenever the fuck you want,
unless you have to do a radio show.
Right?
So it's a different.
The whole world you live in is different
and then you have all this kinky shit
and then you get added addictions to
dirty stuff and so like whatever it is
about like a girl saying something like
that,
she's going to go with me on this crazy
dirty.
A fart in my mouth.
Yeah.
It's like you're,
you're like escaping the troubles.
Just for
a brief moment with all this insane
behavior.
It could be that and I don't know.
Sometimes I wonder like with.
It's almost like if you eat too much ice
cream is diabetes that will come with
that.
That could be the diabetes,
like just too much access and all of a
sudden instead of three to make this
effect,
it takes 11.
It's just it.
You can't get the same effect from the
same thing.
Like when I was growing up,
I loved lesbian porn.
I fucking love to girls.
Oh my God.
It drove me nuts.
Now place.
Are they related?
No,
I'm not interested.
Does nothing that
killed it for me.
When I was on news radio,
one of the guys who was a writer on news
radio is a very nice guy,
but he was a nebbishy sort of fellow
that had problems with women and he was
a writer on news radio and in his
moonlight time you used a pseudonym and
wrote for porn.
Oh.
And so he took me to a porn set is my
first porn set ever.
And it was Jill Kelly and Janine.
I'm sure you know who those Kelly.
I know the name.
Janine and Janine is the one that used
to be married to the Jesse James
Character,
the biker guy.
Oh yes.
Beautiful woman.
And her thing was that she only did a
lesbian porn.
That was her thing.
Right.
So I'm on the set and it was just so,
like clinical,
very,
like it was weird like they were.
They were doing the scene.
Yeah,
that's her.
Yeah.
She was on a blinker on a Tuesday album
cover.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful woman.
Right.
So she's,
um,
she's got this scene as lesbian.
I think she was like a cartoon character
that came back to life or some
ridiculous shit.
Right?
Is that what she looks like now?
Oh Jesus.
Is that a um.
Yeah,
but is that like a spa?
That's a mug shot.
She went to jail.
I forget what she went to jail for it.
But yeah,
not good.
Anyway,
things go south,
right?
That's what we were talking about
earlier.
Some of these gals that get a little
older and all the pressure of the
forbidden behavior,
just the societal pressure and all the
things that lead them to be that way in
the first place come crashing down on
them.
But for,
for this scene like there,
the two of them were on a bed and they
were eating each other's pussies and
there was like this,
uh,
you know,
there was a sound guy with the fuzzy mic
that's on a stick that has hovered over
him.
And then there was a,
another guy that was over there doing
something.
He was literally eating a sandwich where
these girls are eating pussy.
It's like he was so disinterested and
then there was a director and then they
were kind of aware that we were there
watching,
so she was sort of putting on this sort
of self conscious show,
like an in between takes.
They would like,
they go,
okay,
cut.
And she was like,
keep eating her pussy and she would say
something like,
I love my job,
but it was like convincing herself that
she loved her job and it's just like
super bummed me out.
Yeah.
I've been on a bunch of those sets and
you're right.
But there's different energy depending
on the set like I've been on when I
hosted the award show the end with Jenna
Jamison,
so I got to one,
one of her sets and watch.
He actually was doing a lesbian scene.
Her husband at the time,
Jay,
I guess was directing it and that was
like a fucking set.
There was a wardrobe,
there was craft,
you know what I mean?
Like that was a set.
It was a high end sheet at the craft
service.
We,
he,
yeah know I thought I just hot dogs and
Tacos,
I think I just watched her eat pussy.
I'm like,
this is Jenna Jamison.
She is the biggest ever in this
business.
You have to watch this happen.
And then we went on another one.
I saw another one another day where it
was like a lower budget average budget
where it was two guys and a girl and the
girl was in between the two guys and,
but the director was gone,
come on,
let me a little bit more,
a little bit more of that.
And they're,
they're,
they're amazing people that they can
function sexually under those
conditions.
Totally unsexy.
The sexiest one I saw was like a very
low budget,
like a guy,
like one guy with a light and one guy
holding a camera and a couple and they
were like a couple who real amateur.
And so it felt more like sex.
Um,
and I don't think the guy could get hard
for a little while.
He struggled a bit,
but they were real people.
That was the hottest one because it felt
the closest to real sex.
Does that make sense?
That's like,
yeah,
that's actual sex.
I don't like people like those sounds
have too much.
Ah Ha.
The faking it.
Stop it.
I dated a couple girls in porn,
like minor and one girl would blow me
and I could never come from her.
She could head,
but it was like,
that's not good.
Hey,
settle down.
Easy.
Just a little fucking pick it up and
down the mountain.
They gag on purpose.
Like,
hey,
hey.
Hey.
That's nothing for me.
A little gag.
Who likes that?
There are guys that liked that guy named
brandon irons.
I,
he's a Canadian guy with a giant Dick
and he would always.
He's a fucking night.
Who's was a big porn actor for a while.
I remember the fucking Joyce Rivera.
You Know Joey?
Yeah,
I know what that guy is.
Joe.
He's a good friend of mine.
And in,
uh,
I met him at the award show in 2000
January of 2004,
but he's an older gentleman now,
right?
Oh,
he's been late fifties,
early sixties.
Maybe that was he still do porn.
Oh,
he's,
no,
he shoots it.
He shoots a lot of transport,
like yeah,
joey is a fucking,
he's a naughty boy.
He's a great director because he loves
it.
He loves directing because he likes what
he's doing.
So my,
the first time I did the tonight show
was in like September of 2004 I think.
And I watched it at Joey's house
downstairs and I've seen so much porn
shot in that house.
And,
and brandon irons was upstairs with his
girlfriend.
Anyway.
Brandon irons,
his throat fucker.
Like he's the guy look up brands and
Ireland someday that guy will teach a
Canadian dude,
I think he's in Canada now.
He will fucking rip a throat apart and
it's not my thing,
but I think I asked him like,
don't you ever get your Dick Bitten?
Like it just seemed like such a hard way
to have sex and I don't like,
you're going to be uncomfortable.
Like you know what I mean,
like spanking or whatever.
But I don't like to feel like I'm
missing somebody.
That's just not my energy.
Also problem is like if you get hard,
if that's exciting on film,
like is that exciting to you in regular
life or is this just like an act that
you're putting on and film and like how
do you like how sexually,
how does it translate or can you do
both?
Right.
He might be a guy who just can get his
dick hard anywhere.
Like Nacho vidal could literally fuck
during a house fire.
It's just one of those guys that nothing
matters to him.
You know,
Rocco Suffredini,
these guys or,
or a Manuel Ferrara like these guys.
The men impressed me more than the women
just because they have to keep their
dick hard.
I don't know.
A lot of the newer guys,
I just don't really watch as much with
big names,
but the fact that these guys can
function under these conditions,
whereas my dick is very,
very susceptible to having an issue.
Well,
Preval Agora.
There were real superstars,
right?
There were real guys who were just
freaks and now there's like chemically
enhanced superstars,
but even with Viagara have lost heart
on.
It's like I haven't taken salice in over
a month I think,
and maybe it's been three,
actually three or four months now.
I just stopped because my dick was
horrible without it.
I'm like,
I can't even with it,
it was like my dick was kind of half
mast and I'm like,
you're training your body wrong.
So I stopped taking you to talk to
someone to give you that advice.
Um,
what to stop taking it,
you know,
I just knew,
I knew myself.
I was taking it the wrong time and I
wasn't even horny and I'm like,
if you need one,
take it,
but I haven't been sold.
So you were relying on its
psychological?
Oh God,
yeah,
all the time.
Like I thought there might be a chance
that night I'd pop one alice,
go to the seller and hope for the best
was too optimistic sitting there with a
boner.
Yeah,
I mean it just.
And it would make you feel great,
but I didn't need it.
So I,
I kept taking him.
I didn't need.
It sounds like a,
what's a genius thing that nature has
done to make it so that there's all
these different factors that keep you
from getting direct,
right.
Nervousness,
fear,
anxiety,
which makes sense because you really
shouldn't be concentrating.
Like,
because for,
for a human male sex is so
overwhelmingly interesting.
Right?
That you,
if you could get it up in the face of
danger,
it would probably be terrible for your
survival mechanism.
Right?
Right.
Do you read a book called the midnight
of Garden in the middle of the,
uh,
the good with the midnight in the garden
of evil.
What was that?
The Kevin Spacey was in the film,
good and evil in the bid night gardener.
So I'm fucking up.
I know what you're talking about.
Midnight in the garden of good and evil.
Yeah.
I never read that in the garden of Eden.
I read the member of the movie.
I don't,
I.
There was one thing in the book,
I remember years ago,
wow.
Something happened and the guy's fucking
the girl and like somebody came,
they will fucking outdoors and there was
a bad guy who was coming with a gun or
something and she said what she
remembered is that like they couldn't
move,
but she was like,
I remember he stayed hard while he was
inside me and he kept his erection.
I don't even know if it's fiction or
nonfiction.
Something tells me it was nonfiction,
but I could just be hoping.
Um,
I've always envied guys like that,
but I'm not like,
you know,
I'm just,
it's a funny thing to envy.
Well,
yeah,
people who are healthy.
I,
I ended up health necessarily totally
healthy.
Right?
Because you're really healthy.
It'd be thinking about your own
survival.
Someone's got a gun to you.
That's true.
Well,
no,
he was
just in the area.
He wasn't right,
but yeah,
but like the way you are or the way
other guys are who are just like,
hey man,
I kinda liked this girl.
And we connected and it feels right.
Like those guys I,
I envy.
Are you ever completely comfortable?
I'll give you ever like relaxed.
Where you look totally no peace.
Good question.
No,
and I've thought of that recently,
like I'm not comfortable around my own
friends.
Like I love my friends.
I'm comfortable around them but am other
times I'm really comfortable yet
sometimes on the radio when we're going
back and they'd,
when there's no time to think when
there's like fucking six or seven comics
in there and you're just being animals
and everybody's moving and punching and
shitting on each other and we're very
comfortable because there's no time to
reflect or think you just kind of doing
what you do comfortably.
Um,
but in that environment I'm,
I'm,
I,
I realized that after like wow,
I felt like just really alive and great
in the moment,
in the moment is exactly at flowing in a
flow state doing something and not
thinking.
But when I'm thinking I'm always
worrying about this,
who the fucks me up and sexy,
but I know I'm not comfortable too
often,
um,
to do.
Have you ever tried to be?
Yeah.
I don't know what to do.
Like I think it's all shame based.
So I'm trying to think if I talk about
things that helps.
Um,
but if it doesn't it look,
if it hasn't helped to the point where
you're never comfortable now at 49,
it's like,
boy,
this whatever this pattern is that you
followed your whole life,
right.
Might not be the way to do it.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm just guessing.
I think,
you know,
but that's a good point.
I mean it's like,
I don't know why I'm never comfortable.
I'm not sure,
but I'm not,
but that's why I'm asking is asking you
about yoga and that's what I wanted to
ask you about meditation to just a
wonder like maybe you can train your
mind to relax when it comes to certain
things or train your mind to not
entertained so many neurotic thoughts or
train your mind to concentrate on
positive things and eventually build
that up the same way you build up
endurance.
Like for like we were talking about
those guys doing that exercise.
We're circling a persons body like you
burn yourself out unless you did it all
the time.
Or like my friend Cam will runs a
marathon a day.
He's used to it.
He does it all the time.
Like maybe you can do that also with
your point of view.
your mindfulness,
with just thinking about the world
itself around you that you could maybe
not entertain those same thoughts,
these neurotic thoughts.
Maybe those thoughts.
Maybe it's akin to like an endurance
racer giving in to the idea of,
of uh,
discomfort and modern.
I just quit now.
Like maybe there's the same sort of
thing.
Maybe maybe these are mental patterns
that you can sort of stray away from.
Keep your mind on a positive track.
I'm like,
come up with some sort of like really
good ways of thinking about things
because you're obviously a very smart
guy and you're in your,
you're obviously a very sensitive guy.
You think a lot,
you know.
But if you let that thinking and that
sensitivity sort of run a muck without
any control,
without any discipline,
that seems to be the issue.
And I've,
I've had those issues myself in the
past,
which is one of the reasons why I bring
it up.
I mean I'm not,
I'm way healthier now at this point in
my life than I've ever been before
because of really worked at it and
worked at being at peace and being calm
and,
and then also I've worked at all the
extraneous sort of influences that fuck
with that and to sort of eliminate them
and then do use exercise sort of as a
drug in a lot of ways.
Like there's a.
One of the reasons why exercise so much
is because if I don't,
it's not like a looks thing.
It's a mind thing.
Like if I don't strain myself,
if I don't,
if I don't do something really difficult
all the time,
every day I do something five days a
week,
I don't do it everyday.
I have days where I take off,
but if I take more than one day off,
my body starts going,
what are we doing?
What are we doing?
It's almost like you have a dog that you
don't walk your dog.
No,
I know that when you.
This is why one of the reasons why I
thought about it way back in the day
because my dog would be so much calmer
if I went and played with them for a few
hours,
so if I took her for a walk and threw
the ball and he ran around,
he be chill,
but if I did,
he'd be like,
come on,
what's going on?
It's like,
do I have a neurotic dog?
No,
I have a dog that doesn't get any
exercise.
He has physical requirements for him to
be content and I think people have
physical requirements for them to be
content too,
but I think unlike people or unlike dogs
rather people can go on these sort of
downward mental spirals of,
of self hate,
of self analysis,
of a neurosis,
neurotic thinking of you.
You can get yourself in these really bad
patterns of like shitting on yourself or
looking at yourself in a negative way.
You know,
and I think you tend to gravitate
towards these negative things sometimes
and then you,
you realize it and then you bounce back.
But it's like,
what is causing you to gravitate towards
them and why can you never achieve it?
Just a few moments,
like an hour or two.
We just chill.
We could just sit at home and just read
a book and have a cup of tea and just.
Do you ever feel like that?
Were you just comfortable and relax?
Watch a movie on Netflix and chill out.
It's always restless if you tell it.
The mental patterns and changing the
physical stuff is what I gotta do first
they bring the body and the mind will
follow.
So I have to stop doing certain things.
And this thing of not cheating on this
girl is it [inaudible] I've not cheated
on girls before when they were here,
but she's not here yet and we're still
in a relationship.
And for me to not it it's miraculous
that I'm not.
And we had a fight recently and I almost
did.
I started fucking tech and I'm like,
no,
you can't see what you do.
Sabotage things.
And that's why you're so um,
and I've been going kind of up and down
lately.
But it's like whenever you're not doing
something you,
it takes a while for you to adjust and
go like,
all right,
when you feel something now you've got
to feel it.
You can't feel it.
And then run and go on eroes.
Do you ever go to a therapist?
Oh yeah.
Many,
many others.
One I went to,
she was very nice,
but once I started getting familiar with
them,
you know,
there was one time I forget why I was
really fucking
suicidal and I called her.
I don't like calling a therapist.
It was a bad day.
And I was talking to her.
What triggered it?
No,
it's usually the same stuff around
feeling like a failure.
It just the same shit that everybody has
the same feeling like I'm worthless.
So I talked to her and um,
uh,
she was being nice but she was not being
helpful and I didn't want her to rescue
me,
but I wonder just simply to give some
kind of an answer or trigger me to ask
myself a question.
As a therapist,
do they trigger you to go,
why am I doing?
It's my fucking.
That's what their job is.
Nonsense.
She was,
she just not very good at it.
No.
She was like,
yeah,
no,
I know.
Let's just kind of empathizing a little,
but I'm like,
I don't need you to fucking empathize
with me.
I just need you to just give me a
suggestion on something.
Don't just be okay.
This is where we're at.
All right now.
I'll see you next week.
You really might not.
You know what I mean?
I didn't say that to her because I'm
not,
I don't like to,
you know,
I'm not a fucking emo girl,
but I just was like,
all right,
whatever.
Um,
but I feel like I can't be in a
therapist therapy with her anymore.
Well,
I think therapists are probably a lot
like comics,
right?
There's really good ones and there's
really bad ones.
Ones that some people think are really
good and you might think suck.
You know what I mean?
There's just,
I haven't gotten yours.
I mean a few years,
but uh,
I feel better now than I have in a long,
long time.
Like I'm happy now.
I'm just,
I'm fucked up lately because I'm kind of
going through this huge change,
but other than that I feel better than I
have in a long time.
Like life is good.
That's good.
I love the radio show I'm doing.
I have fun with Sam.
Everybody really do like,
you know,
I enjoy working with Sam.
He's a fucking goof ball and I have fun.
I love doing the thing with Matt.
Like I just,
I have fun doing that stupid fucking
chip is the biggest thing in my life and
I love doing it.
But character,
why is that?
The people love it.
Like the podcast they're going to hate
this week because we did it in La and
the women didn't know chip was and it
was very ugly experience last week.
They would just from that.
This uh,
Maria Menounos,
his boyfriend,
Kevin Undergaro,
he runs this place.
They do all these after show.
He's a huge chip fan.
So he's like,
Hey,
while you're out here you can use my
studio because I have a podcast because
that's.
I can't teach.
It's a different hair every week.
I can't look.
I can't look at it.
It's fucking humiliating.
I love the face.
You make me do it.
A different wig on every week.
Every week.
Yeah.
The glasses,
those are glasses that Colin Quinn gave
me to fuck.
But it's,
it's so awful.
But the last one we released as a live
one and it's the people we was an hour
and 20 minutes long.
We did it the village underground and
it's sold out faster than anything I've
sold in years.
It's fucking ridiculous character.
You know what it is.
And,
and it was a fun shy at Collin,
Anthony fucking Sam was on,
um,
uh,
who have lost their fucking Bobby Kelly
and it was just so silly.
And the people I think is,
it's almost like everybody's greatest
fear is to be that on aware.
Like that's a weird,
like why do people like this?
Because the joke stink if fucking
terrible jokes.
And they said with conviction,
but she always has people around him who
know him doing it this week in La was me
and Sam and x park was on,
who was a fun guy.
But he knows me as the wrestler who
fucked China in the porn.
He was extra.
There's a great guy.
He,
uh,
means more than a guy who fuck China,
but that's using the reference people
have.
Well no,
but he knows Jim,
so he's like,
hey,
check is trying to go with it,
but he doesn't know what to do.
And these fucking four girls that have
no idea because Kevin wanted it to be a
train wreck.
Fucking fucking Kevin Underdog.
He wanted to be a train wreck.
So he had these girls.
He didn't tell him a little while,
go here,
Jim Warren's going to be there to huge
podcast from New York.
So I fucking do it.
And they're trying to go with it and
chip just an abrasive.
They didn't know what to do.
I was the only time I've ever been
humiliated doing chip.
I was embarrassed and uncomfortable.
And I also like,
this is what it's supposed to be.
This guy stinks when you supposed to be
disliked because people were in on the
joke,
loved the joke,
you know?
And,
and they get that the jokes are awful.
So the fun point with people who love it
is to,
at times give one,
like my ex girlfriend really new chip
and there was times I would do a is so
bad.
And she was like,
oh,
that's fucking terrible.
Like she loved.
Don't you think that the people that
love chipotle actually love this episode
then because it's chip interacting with
people who have no idea who he is.
If they really love chip,
if they understand who chip jepperson
really is,
they're going to go fucking bananas.
I can't even watch it.
Dude.
I can't watch it.
I was embarrassed because Sam,
you with me.
I'm like,
dude,
is it that?
And he goes,
it was really uncomfortable.
I'm now I'm compelled people to get it.
There are people who really who didn't
videotape it to,
oh,
we videotape every one ion video and
it's on Youtube for free.
Like,
I waited on itunes as well,
all for free.
I make a little money from the Ed and I
said,
I want to charge with the video.
I want to do something with it someday.
I don't know where it will go.
We've only been doing it a few months.
Um,
you know,
I think that this is like,
I've 25 episodes.
We do one a week.
He does live reads.
Yeah.
Give me some volume.
Fucking slammed Ya Dad fucking head.
I'm call.
Watched it go.
Was that fun?
Love.
You look like a Honolulu.
Hipster.
Yeah.
What's that say?
Fucking Honolulu.
Hipster.
Fucking upstate New York.
You have pizza,
garbage,
Honolulu in Hawaii,
you know,
stupid
nonsense.
Now,
when did you,
you came up with this character when you
were on.
Oh,
and a what?
What made you do this?
Like girlfriends hated it.
I think we talked with his girlfriend
drove me.
They hated it so much because it was
humiliating and I,
it got a reaction out of them and I just
kept doing it so much.
It was so much fun.
And a lot of times I,
anthony,
like at first hated it,
but then anthony started to love it.
But then opie never loved it.
It was always kind of fun to do because
I knew like deep down uncle Paulie
hates.
So I would always do uncle Paul just to
fucking make him sick because he
couldn't get with uncle Paul.
Anthony,
of course.
Could you more comfortable now doing it
without him?
The radio show?
Much much Yo.
Yeah.
We stopped liking each other.
I mean,
the reality is we are,
you know,
I really mean I don't wish the guy bad
in his real life,
like I don't want bad shit to happen to
them.
But uh,
we simply stopped liking each other.
So,
um,
but he,
he was enjoying his afternoon show much
more without me.
Then he was with me.
Um,
I got the morning spa,
spa or whatever,
you know,
um,
I think the company just was annoyed at
him or whatever they like to be in San.
We're hungry.
But his afternoon show was good.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
he,
him and shirod and those guys,
they were having fun.
So people didn't like it,
they didn't like it,
but he sounded like he was having fun
and he was looking at him fired.
Like what,
what happened,
what the technical reason was,
was um,
he had filmed role in campus.
Our booker taking a shit.
Um,
now I know,
Oop,
well he filmed me doing it in 2009,
but he was being a goofball.
I don't think he was trying to be
degrading just being an ass and then I'm
showing it to I think a couple of the
comics and I guess I don't know exactly.
I heard about it after the ball had
already been rolling,
so somehow role and got nervous that he
was going to release it and maybe with
tea,
I don't know what role he said to them,
I really don't,
but I think that it got back to one of
Roland's bosses and then the head of the
talent department spoke to them and then
once human resources got involved then
things change.
And I remember there was a clip of it
was getting bad and there was another
producer in the studio named Paul and he
was videotaping it and I think he had
been unrolling side and he thought he
was being a dick to him.
He's going to be a dick to me.
Nobody's like,
yeah,
because you chose rolling in this whole
thing,
like making it a public thing.
That was really uncomfortable.
And then Paul goes,
yeah,
well I thought it was wrong.
And then she,
rod goes like,
ah,
he was having fun.
We all saw the tape,
he was enjoying it,
he was laughing and when I heard that,
I'm like,
oh no,
he just said we all saw the tape.
So other like that just made it.
And again,
maybe they were going to fire them
anyway,
I don't know,
like they don't tell me that shit.
Um,
but he thinks that the company was out
to get him.
I don't know.
And again,
I kind of know what they said to him
privately,
but to me he had two months left on his
deal and no company wants to fire you
two months out because.
Because the potential lawsuits loss,
they would much rather let you ride it
out and then just not resign.
You will serious isn't a weird place
because of podcasts.
Yes.
I mean it's just a very weird place that
the idea of paying money for these talk
shows that are going to get interrupted
by commercials and to have to listen to
them only when they come on and not have
them on demand.
It's such an inferior distribution where
they demand like now
now they're on demand is getting your
phone an hour after it's up.
You can get it an hour after it's but
live you can listen live on the phone
and get it to.
What I'm saying is on your radio,
like if you're in your car and you,
you,
you can't just pick.
I want to listen to Tuesdays opie and
Anthony Show or Jim Norton and Sam show.
I can't just pick that.
I don't know if you can,
unless you have a phone,
it might be a way to do it.
That phone hooked up.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
Right.
But I don't think you could do that.
Like Sirius radio is only playing what's
playing right now?
I think so far I don't know her.
I mean I don't have a thing where I
could just pick an episode.
How is the podcast played in a car?
You could just get.
There's a bunch of different ways.
One,
you can do it where you could stream it
live through youtube.
Some people do that and you just play
the audio and if you have it setup,
you can play the video.
Some people do it where you,
uh,
you're on stitcher,
stitcher is a low bit rate version,
meaning it's a,
the audio quality's not as good because
it's compressed,
but it's way quicker to download.
So if you have some sort of a plan where
you want to get a less data per month,
a lot of people use stitcher or they
just get it off of itunes.
But the thing about it is that you just,
if you have your phone bluetooth up,
you literally,
all you have to do is press play and
it'll immediately play like whatever
episode like you to scroll through,
scroll through our stuff.
If you go to Syria now too,
on the new operating system,
just like ask for it.
Yeah,
you could play it for Siri.
But if you go through,
have you ever done,
do you use it?
Do you use a itunes or a podcast APP?
I never look at podcast standing by like
my most recent ones.
Of all the ones that I subscribe to that
I can just take one,
click it and boom,
now it's playing.
Yeah,
I mean that's just,
it's done differently on serious.
Yeah.
The APP you have to use.
The on demand is pretty good,
but it's,
I think it's an hour after it as you can
get it forever.
I believe.
I don't list.
I don't really listen to the show.
I mean I never listened to our show.
Um,
I listened to it on drives and like wow,
I kinda like it.
Um,
it's,
it's new.
We finally got anthony back in the
building.
I'm allowed to come on as a guest in the
I fought for three years for that and
literally right after he got fired,
they let him anthony back in after.
I hope you got fired.
And I'm not saying that he kept them.
I don't know.
It could be really honest.
Um,
I don't think that he actively kept him
out.
No.
Do they know the real numbers?
Like did they ever tell you how many
people were actually listening?
Never.
I don't know if they know.
I mean,
I don't know how they would track that.
They may,
but they don't apply to me.
It's like I really want to know will
give us the negotiating power on a part
of me is like,
I really don't want to know,
but the fact that we're getting raises,
I think we're doing okay.
Like I,
that's the only way I can tell you right
is that they,
I know that they want to,
to keep me every time the contract said
okay,
we must be doing okay.
Um,
but no,
I don't know what the numbers are,
just,
it's amazing how quickly it became a
different thing,
you know,
like,
like I remember when Howard went to
serious,
it was like,
wow,
how Lulea finally we're going to get
uncensored radio.
And then
it became,
well it's still just radio and still
live in,
now you have to pay for it and now it's
10 bucks a month.
And mean he made out like a bandit.
I mean he made ridiculous sums of money
from it,
but where's the future in that?
It just seems like that's a,
it's,
it's like almost like investing in.
I mean if you're,
if you're someone who's got a piece of
that,
it's like where's that going?
Like how are you going to keep.
You can't even use it in a tunnel.
You know,
the thing with serious and this is this
really the scary for job security,
but they have really.
Scott is good at getting big name
talent,
like a Beatles channel on all this
stuff.
They're good at getting good name,
good name,
a big name.
People doing shows Ferguson's on their
channel.
Yeah.
I'm not a faction where it goes.
We're all in faction now.
Faction talk.
Yeah.
I hate the name [inaudible].
It doesn't say comedy,
but whatever it is,
what it is.
It's us and then Camino and and then
Ellis and then Craig and then Nick
Depalo was a very funny show.
Who's the lawyer?
Nick is a fucking savagely funny guy.
Love that guy.
He's just a fucking raw fucking bark out
a joke.
Funny Guy like mick is.
Here's the thing about nick.
He's never afraid to try to be funny.
Like I've done a lot of projects with
them.
We get tough crowd for two years.
I've just done a shitload of stuff back,
back,
back like Nicholas fucking fire lines
out and I've always admired him for that
because sometimes they work,
sometimes they don't,
but he's unafraid is a funny fucking
dude and he's unafraid to bark stuff out
and be who he is.
Like I love that.
And he does a great show.
He's a really surprisingly good radio
guy.
Like,
but go into breaks and all that stuff.
But yeah,
Athens doing it for a long time with rd.
Remember?
That's right,
yes,
I was on the show,
but I remember watching the one blow out
that they had where nick was trying to
do some read that they had already.
Didn't just want it to kind of fuck off.
You can't let it get to you like that.
We've had the blow outs.
I've been thRough them,
I've seen them.
Me and it never had one I love and one
of my fucking.
I just wrote the foreword to his book.
I don't know,
I'm supposed to say that,
but too bad.
I'm proud of it.
I fucking love him.
And he's doing a show with already now.
Right.
The a show,
the fucking greatest name.
They had a great billboard for it and
uh,
it's really funny man.
It's to listen to that.
Do it for the,
to the compound yet.
How much does that cost?
I honesTly don't know.
I do pay for it though.
He offered me a free one,
but I'm like,
oh,
I'll chime in.
I mean I'll fucking,
I'll chip in and it's doing well.
Framed that whole compound meal.
Yeah.
He hasn't skipped a beat.
His life is fucking doing great.
Yeah.
there's not a great thing to our their
mugshot.
They're real legit.
Mugshots hilarious.
They did it.
Yeah.
Compound media.
I like how he called it compound media
too because.
Oh,
look at the aaa show.
A great poster.
September fifth.
Now.
Can you get that on your phone?
You can get it on an app.
I have the anthony put it in the car.
You can listen to it in the car.
He's a but yeah,
he's.
I love him too.
He's one of my favorite people ever.
He's literally somebody who I don't
think I'll ever not be close to.
There's no one create like I love sam.
I love all these guys I've worked with,
but anthony,
that was a weird.
It's a comic thing that happens when
you're going back and forth,
but some of this in energy you're
exchanging and with do it.
There are jim norton laugh compilations.
I never lived on my own shit.
I don't listen to the old show.
I can't listen to it,
but those I can listen to because
they're all anthony just making me
laugh.
It's not me saying funny shit,
it's anthony saying funny shit that
every time fucking gets me.
Like he would literally make me laugh
like that wheeze laugh than an audience
member gets.
I'm like,
I never get to fucking feel that way,
but he's not even.
What's the craziest.
he's not a standup.
He's not a standup.
He's done it a little bit,
but in that rotating.
Yeah,
he tried it.
A couple of [inaudible] in montreal a
couple of years ago just to do it.
Yeah,
after he had been fired.
oh my god.
no,
no.
This is what opie and anthony were
supposed to do,
a show together to host a comedy show in
montreal.
I was part of the show,
but I'll be at home for some reason.
He flew home a day early,
didn't want to do it,
so I did it by himself and hosted the
show and started shitting on the
comedians and he was really funny.
First time ever on stage.
he was fucking funny.
Wow.
But in a,
in a comic room.
Patrice said that about him.
He said,
he said anthony can access funny faster
than any person.
I've ever seen and patrice didn't hand
out.
You would not known as the big ol boy,
that guy dolan out compliments again
write down.
There's not patrice is reputation,
but anthony has that ability to reach in
and grab funny from anywhere and he's as
fast as any comic we've ever had on a.
There's never been a comedian in there
who was faster than him.
They'd been as fast as him guys like
patrice or burro genius,
but there's no one has ever been able to
go in there and run circles around
anthony.
It's staggering how fucking funny that.
Yeah,
it is weird.
It's like he's a comic who never became
a comic,
but that's how I've always felt about
being around him and he even said that
about him and dice was shitting on
opiod.
Anthony when they had a few together,
he was saying that that anthony is
actually talented and he's actually
almost like a comic,
but he never did it.
He never did it.
and anthony has an ability brewers and
amazing storyteller to an amazing
storyteller.
Whereas aunt could do that about like he
can literally tell you.
he would talk about like,
you know,
being a tin knocker and stuff I have no
knowledge of or interest in and,
and he would have me on the edge of my
seat listening to him talk about it.
He just has a gift for explaining things
anD for walking you through it.
Louis has that.
The ability to explain an amazingly
interesting fashion and anthony can just
jump in and out of voices and do
impressions.
I mean,
I never get sick of rambling about him
because I got to work with them for a
fucking decade.
I got to work with the funniest guy in
the fucking world for a decade.
Like,
as much as it sucks that it's over,
like I'm grateful.
I just want to do it again.
One hundred percent.
Have you thought about doing that?
I would love to go with him and sam.
I mean me and open don't get along
anymore.
Um,
but I would love to have anthony with me
and sam.
But again,
he's got his own show.
It's not going to happen,
but I love salmon.
I have a very good chemistry and a
comfort level.
Like I,
I like him and I trusted him on the air
and with opiate just got bad.
I'm not blaming him.
It's like,
hey,
I always have the problem too.
But what about you doing a show with
anthony?
Compound media,
compound media.
Is he get into a more enclosed
environment than serious is and because
of gigs and other things I got to
promote.
I just kinda,
I wanted to stay and also serious pays
more and I didn't want to negotiate
against anthony.
I just couldn't.
I was like,
hey,
I wasn't going to use him as a
negotiation tactic.
I didn't want to do.
I couldn't do it.
I'm too close to him and I always kind
of secretly wanted him to come back.
And when he came back the first day he
came back.
I mean it was seeing that fucking I got,
I got the,
we went to a springsteen know who
played.
Oh,
guns and roses played at the fucking the
apollo.
So this was like right after opening it
to fire.
So I saw scott greenstein that night or
andrew and like,
Yeah,
he can come in and kill me,
and I'm like,
really?
They're like,
yeah,
you can come in.
And I'm like,
great.
I texted him,
come in tomorrow,
the minute he could come in and uh,
but security hadn't been told so I'm on
the show and I know ants coming in.
It's gonna be a fucking surprise for the
audience.
But he's being held up at security
because in fairness they needed an email
from scott they didn't know that had
been okayed and it took about an hour or
40 minutes,
but he got up and seeing him walk down
that ah,
fuck.
it was so good.
He was happy.
Very rarely see that on his face.
It was so good.
But,
but you,
you just go right back into that.
And sam is so perfect in that moment
till you just kind of go back into it
and you flow and you know.
So I miss him a lot,
but uncensored conversations,
they're just hard to come by.
And When you're under the corporate
umbrella,
you're not really uncensored.
There's always gonna be something that
you can't say something,
get you in trouble,
which is why I was always encouraging
you to do a podcast.
Like wait,
even way back in the day,
I was like,
you should branch out and you should do
something on the wrong side.
I feel like people wouldn't.
Why voice felt people wouldn't want it
or they were sick of me or they're not
interested.
but again,
the closest I've come at this point is
fucking dumb.
Chip,
I made you my own sunday,
but I,
I'm literally loving doing that.
It's freedom and it's fun.
Do what you love then,
but you know,
I mean,
I know you love doing the sam and jim
show too,
but I really feel like even that show
would be bigger if it was just
accessible to everybody and not on
serious.
It might be.
And again,
we have one more year left on the
contract and it is something I would do
as a podcast.
It absolutely is something I would do as
a podcast,
but they don't want to say one thing in
their favor.
Besides the fact that like,
yeah,
there's human resources and you know,
you can't go around and fucking grabbing
clits they never fuck with us
creatively.
Like literally never say nothing with
condoleezza rice where you guys got
kicked off the air.
that was a homeless guy.
Here's what that was,
that your right to homeless charlie.
And he's like,
what?
Bad?
That bush bItch.
He was just a funny fucking dude.
Here's how that got pushed.
That was before sirius xm merged and
what sunk,
what it will almost happened was that
made it to fucking brietbart or
breitbart and then got onto drudge and
then became a big deal and I heard later
that the people who were making that a
story where the people who worked in
terrestrial radio who did not want that
merger to happen.
So the only reason the company pulled
him off if they were literally scared
that it was going to hurt whatever they
needed in congress for fucking two to
make the merger.
Haptics.
I'm serious.
So they were saying it was a merger in
danger.
Like once that got out there and fucking
either way,
we shouldn't have been off the air,
but I'm as crazy as it was,
that's where terrestrial radio saved us
because k rock who they wanted to be off
the fucking show.
Those cons.
I hate that they wanted you.
Yeah,
because the ratings weren't as good as
they used to be and they thought I was
the probleM.
Let's say.
Hey fucking shit heads.
I was there in the afternoon when we'd
be for syndication.
I was loving anthea before they're ever.
I love people go like,
yeah,
dude,
you suck.
I remember philadelphia before you were
on.
No you don't.
It didn't happen before I was on.
There was no philly shell before I was
on.
I was always there and syndication,
so whatever.
anyway,
they went to bergen once.
People are.
I know,
I know.
I do that.
I literally will do that alone.
I,
I don't.
I didn't realize that people don't talk
to themselves.
I didn't realize that.
And with chip and the character's eyes,
and I've talked about this on our show,
I do it all the time by myself.
You have conversations with full blown
chip edgar.
Oh,
full volume talking.
I'll little them and character not once
in a while if I think of something is
dead.
Girls say it in a lot of sector.
Yeah.
He's another one.
He's a bad character and he's just has
dry teeth.
He said there's not a whole lot to them,
but I would do them because anthony is,
he touches you with a sharp fingernails.
It's an ugly thing.
Uh,
and uncle paul,
I,
I do them.
And you do them when you're alone.
Completely alone.
Wow.
And I do.
When I'm alone,
if I drop something,
I'll go,
oh,
okay.
That's about it.
I'll walk around and talk to myself and
full blown conversation like,
uh,
this,
this is not.
I have actually embarrassed this.
I took a shit today and I got up and I
was done and I,
I went to the fucking to look at my
computer and I had to shit again
immediately.
And I stood up and out loud.
I said,
oh,
that's just jostled a little more loose,
and I walked back to the toilet.
I said those words to myself alone.
I do it all the time,
dude.
I talk and I didn't know.
I thought everyone did that,
but sam's like,
no,
I'll think things,
but I don't say them.
Yeah,
I would imagine most people think
things,
but a few people talk to themselves.
I'm sure I've done it on occasion,
but it's not a normal in the shower.
I do it out loud just for conversation
to me when I'm alone,
I'm happy to not talk.
I talked so fucking much.
I talk so much doing a podcast so much
doing stand up so much doing ufc
commentary when I can not talk at all.
I'm fucking happy.
Yeah.
I don't know what it is.
It's like things that just kind of come
out or I work through things or I worked
through this girlfriends argument,
you know,
whatever it is in the moment,
and I logically talk things through,
but yeah,
that's where a lot of the characters
should come from is.
I'll start thinking of it and I'll talk
in a weird voice and there'll be
something that resonates with me and I'm
like,
I'm stuck in my head man.
And once It's stuck in my head down,
I bring it out on the air and that's
when it gets stuck in everybody else's
head.
Like if it's bothering me for a month,
it's,
you're going to hate it,
you know?
And I like to bring that stuff out.
That's what I have to check comes from
just being single and lonely.
I've got to wrap this up.
Okay.
There will be so much fun with joe.
Always a good time,
brother.
AnytIme you're in town,
man,
just let me know.
Let's do this more often.
Can I play my nearly room?
Only all tickets are on sale if you want
to go.
And uh,
I'm in dallas and austin this week and
the money's going to the hurricane
victims.
I hate saying that.
It feels cheesy,
but I feel worse going into prostituting
tickets,
right?
Um,
and uh,
go to the,
a check being sam out or go to jim
norton.com
and I'll go to the chip.
Chip person,
riot casts,
youtube has all the chip podcasts up
there and uh,
this one,
this week is going to be a fucking
doozy.
thanks norton.
Ladies and gentlemen.